what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in um let's get
started so we have a couple
announcements before we start the show
I'm the first guys you already know two
clips channels just pearly clips and
pearl daily also guys um we have an
amazing merch line okay if you if you're
a guy and you're thinking how can I get
random women to come up and just talk to
me in public right I know you're
thinking like how can I just get the
ladies chatting to me it's annoying
approaching them what if women could
approach you well I have the solution
for you are women shouldn't vote
t-shirts are available now you'll get
women of all ages and really of all all
different types of women coming up and
saying wow that's an amazing t-shirt
you're so right you have so many awesome
thoughts so you know um the link to that
is in the description so make sure you
get um the t-shirts it is a pre-order
right now now but we should get the
shirts in like a week and then we'll
we'll show you them firsthand you know
also um four membership tiers um if you
want first tier you get to be a part of
our live chat fourth um and how many
likes to open up the live chat tonight
King
a thousand five hundred okay a thousand
five hundred likes tonight and we will
open up the chat for everybody if you
guys have a comment question concern
please Super Chat it and please guys
don't be too rude like I know you guys
like roasting all of us but it's very
awkward I'm gonna read them still no
offense guys but it's like awkward if
you if you roast too hard so for me okay
please so how over how many um dollars
do we read 20 okay over twenty dollars
we will read the super chats be nice
yeah yeah I see you guys in the chat all
right okay so also my Instagram just
pearly things one if you have any ideas
things you want me to cover in the show
or in my news show Pearl daily that we
do five a week send them to me there
um and sign up for our Google email list
um we're gonna do an event soon I'm
thinking Halloween I know I've been
gaslighting you guys about this event
for months but it's happening we met
with a studio place today so we're gonna
do an event maybe on Halloween or my
birthday so those are all my
announcements
um today we have a great panel welcome
guys why don't we start
um name age relationship status and a
fun fact about yourself starting here
and then go around okay I'm fatty I'm
23. I'm from Paris okay and uh fun facts
[Music]
you have any hobbies Hobbies
um
outside is to play football okay yeah
what a fun fact
[Laughter]
okay so my name is Cynthia I'm 29. uh
I'm from France as well and a fun fact
um
I have no idea honestly I love to cook
that's okay what's your favorite dish my
favorite dish I would say sweet and sour
chicken okay I gotta tell you something
I'm gonna tell you this is between me
and you it's gonna be a secret okay I
know the difference between girls that
say they cook and actually cook because
the girls that say they cook they always
have one answer
steak
I don't say steak I'm like she might
actually cook see okay um go ahead hi my
name is amra I'm 26 and I'm from London
a fun fact about me I love horror films
and I like acting what what's your
favorite horror film
um Jackie Springs to mind it's not my
favorite but it's one actually I really
like um Insidious all of the Insidious
films you know I'm trying to remember
there are some paranormal activities
that was the first like horror movie I
saw and I felt so cool because I snuck
into it as a kid yeah I was I was pretty
badass and Freddy Krueger
my name is Judah from London
um 35 years old
um something fun about me is I just love
music All Things music that's me all
things musical fashion what's your
what's your favorite song My Favorite
Song right now
um favorite song right now of a new
album would have to be one of giggs's
songs and one of his songs right now is
called call me okay and also Hallelujah
so that's it now another question Kanye
or Drake
I
need the trouble to be stirred
I listen to more Drake than I do Kanye
but I respect Carney more than Drake
that's always What I Hear Drake's like
you can kind of sing do his stuff yeah
you just got that music you just relate
to it you bop your head yeah the
production is great Kanye he's a bit out
there you have to really tap into what
he's going through to kind of dig what
you're saying I got you that way who's
who's this lovely young lady
I don't
hi I am I'm Christine I'm 22 also from
London uh I'm in a relationship and fun
fact about me I'm actually a YouTuber
here at the audacity Network yeah and
subscribe to our Channel guys we want to
get her to 20K this month what's what is
it Christine Grace is that the name
Christine Grace Smith okay I was like I
don't remember what we made the YouTube
name Christine Graceman all right all
right so
um you know I've done
I don't even know what episode this is
over like 150 roughly shows here and
being this it's mostly women that come
on to the show right um so I've I think
it we logged it we had over 600 women in
the past year and a half just in this
apartment right yeah and that's between
like we've done dating shows we've done
these type of shows and I notice a
pattern okay and this pattern was
pointed out by the late and great
um Kevin Samuels so I want I want to
show you guys a clip and I want you guys
to tell me if you agree or you disagree
you're not single by choice
your choices are made you single but
you're not single by choice I'm like
this don't miss no he's
good that don't
miss man he's good In the Heat of battle
he don't miss no In the Heat of
controversy he don't miss
so yeah I've I've done these shows and
we always do the intros and I I just I
get that it's so common I'm single by
choice
and yeah so do you think there's a such
thing as single by choice and what does
it mean
I would say that hmm
I would say that I'm single by choice
because
I haven't met someone that
I can project myself with or that he's
good enough for me I would say okay well
if I really wanted to be in a
relationship tomorrow I would have been
in a relationship why would I have been
a good relationship for me okay what do
you think yeah I disagree with what he
says because I believe that you can be
single by choice but I agree as well
when he's saying that um it's because
the choice are available to you are not
what you want so that means it's not
really a choice but I believe I'm single
by choice okay
okay wait so let me let me rewind there
so you agree with him I disagree on the
fact that I'm single by church right now
because that's a choice that I've made
okay every single but I understand that
there is other women that is because the
choices that you want are not available
to you and that's the reason why you're
single okay so I have a question what
does your dream man look like
wow
my dream man will be
a little a leader okay
um someone that is strong and respectful
and respectable enough for me to follow
him and be led by him okay a provider a
real traditional man okay that's what we
say okay see you on a traditional
provider mail yes anything else does he
have to be tall uh not really what about
shorter than you
but you have to be confident are you
guys friends yeah
are you guys do you know each other from
before today she's my friend friend oh
you met her today yeah yeah okay I
wasn't sure if you knew each other
before no we have someone in common oh
okay okay okay so if a traditional man
came up to you and said will you go on a
date with me and would you say yes yeah
why not
okay
okay thank you God
um I agree because I agree in a sense
because I think it is because of lack of
available options I think well that's my
reason for being single because of lack
of available options I don't think
there's many options out there
um I'd say I've got quite high standards
and there's not many they might be
really good looking or the personalities
lacking or there's something else
there's always something but there's
there's not many options I feel like in
London or in the UK okay what do you
think all right well I'm not a woman and
the question is um whether women really
single by choice
now I believe that there's two sides to
the queen obviously one
the modern women right now the cars that
they're being dealt on the ideal cards
hence the reason why a lot of women are
single you feel what I'm saying aside
from that there are women that have got
that choice I have a career driven I've
had enough of what's happened in the
past ever just not on that wavelength
right now to be committed in a
relationship that would decide to be
single by choice so it's a very
double-sided answer with that question
because
everything subjective to the individual
ultimately so me personally are more
than women single by choice I would
think the majority no but some yes okay
and the some that are yes it's because
they just picked something else over
yeah they've picked something else over
they've had enough of the past and
nothing's kind of really tickled their
fancy following who's an example of like
a celebrity that you'd say a single by
choice oh a celebrity that's single by
choice
wow
I can't really think of single
celebrities right now off the top of my
head my head I think if it was before
but I've Been Rihanna Kim Kardashian
maybe Kim Kardashian Kim Kardashian I
don't think she's single by a chance
[Music]
you could be in Russian but right now
she's not really dating out there
someone
do you think Kim K isn't dating no she
is
out there that is very easy committed
thank you very much okay coming to the
relationship yeah all right so yeah I
can't think of an example of um a single
person that is not a single celebrity
that's not you know by choice but
um that's a bit of a chicken okay what
about like Taylor Swift is she single by
choice you see I don't even follow
Taylor Swift
um so the women are there women in your
life that you could think of that are
single by choice yeah my sister's single
by choice so I had to blow you up sis
okay what did she choose over a
relationship well well based on the lack
of Calabar that's out there she's not
gonna settle so women that tend to not
settle will be the ones that are single
by choice because they're not going to
just be in a relationship how old is
your sister she's 46. do you think at 36
she would be settling for a guy or they
would be settling for her no she would
be sitting for God because she's high
value in regards to what she brings to
the table to my knowledge so therefore
36 yeah what do you bring to a guy at
36. well you bring to a guy at 36 is
your quality of life your morals how
you've been brought up the things that
you're able to do what is that what's
the point of dating do you think the
point of dating is to be with somebody
in a partnership and um kind of have the
same kind of goal and right work towards
that um destination but like like
historically like what what has been the
point of being in relationships marriage
marriage and and children right so so at
36 geriatric pregnancy started a year
before if you're single by 30 as a woman
you only have like
um I think you're more likely to not
have children than to have them so at 36
it's like it's probably that's probably
not going to happen for her okay so
that's like the number one point of
dating so it's like would the guy be
wouldn't the guy be settled and I feel
bad because you're so sorry
but like would it wouldn't the guy be
settling for her because she's 36. well
I don't think so at all because like I
said there's a lot of things that she
brings to the table that would obviously
have the person of the be to the guy's
discretion whether they're gonna be okay
with the fact that she's that age and
she hasn't had that yeah she hasn't yet
so that order will be subjective to the
guy that gets involved but based on what
she brings to the table it would never
be a settling what do you think men
typically want from men typically want
from a woman is peace
um understanding
um support
um and also I believe a kid okay do 36
year old career women typically bring
that it's by choice subjective
everything is something do you think if
like their dream man came up if her
dream man came up to her
um that she would say yes if I dream
well yeah of course so then wouldn't it
not be a choice wouldn't it just be that
the men she wants don't want her no it
wouldn't be that because the question is
do are they is she single by choice and
she's single by the choice that the
person that hasn't come up to her is not
a dream man yet correct which which
typically means you don't qualify for
the men you want no it doesn't mean that
it means that you could not be in the
right place you're not might not be in
the right space you might not be in the
right location for that to be attracted
do the men do the men that women
typically want they exist right they do
okay right and they do and far between
us right and they and they typically
pick wives at some point right
ultimately yeah well in this day and age
no but yeah well yeah I mean a lot of
them do belong to the streets forever
but but but yeah I mean the one there
are ones that do get married 100 and if
you look at like the richest men they do
end up getting married yeah right like
I'm divorced but yeah
I mean yeah yeah yeah but but so like to
me it indicates that it's just the men
that single women want aren't asking
them out meaning we don't qualify
and I think it's actually like in my
opinion a disservice to us to think
anything differently because it says we
don't need to improve at all
no I mean I get that but in this
instance of the single woman who's that
age and that kind of right because at
that point 36 you start dating at 16
that's 20 years
it's a lot of time it's took a lot of
time and a lot of experience here but
it's all subjective to what you do with
your time and ultimately it all depends
on the person you find are you aligned
if you're aligned it will work and if
you're not aligned it won't do good
wives typically put family or their
career first good wives have put their
family first I believe okay so so again
it kind of It kind of begs the question
if at 36 it's like what if you put your
career first until you know
not 10 years but 20 years it seems like
that doesn't make for a good wife
ultimately it just means timing
everything is based on timing whether it
be God's time Divine time the universe
is time everyone has their time I see
and I believe so whenever that time
comes whichever the woman is whether
she's 36 38 24 25 yeah the time will
come and that person will be their
person or not yeah and I think that
really sounds nice and I think that
really that really it really does sound
nice but that's my choice well I know we
could have your truth or the truth right
what is it what is well I I think the
truth is there's General things that men
want right it's usually fertility Beauty
youth femininity right and typically if
you're not getting picked then typically
there's there's something that probably
I remember but wait wait wait but
there's probably something that needs to
improve right and every girl it's
different right
um but it's like how do we fix it if we
don't even know there's a problem and
the men say it's oh it's it's divine
timing when typically you know when I
think of um the most fit feminine
friendly women that I know they were all
pretty much scooped up before 25 sure
you know so and then the longevity of
what they're in is also subjective and
determined of what their circumstances
at the time the person I'm talking about
that's 36 that hasn't got that yet it's
not about them not being whole enough to
have that is sometimes about not finding
what they say perfect is my sister
perfect yeah I'm not saying it's not
room for improvement for anybody right
anybody has room for improvement
everybody has to move my sister included
right but remember the question was are
me relating to my sister was that she's
single by choice based on what she
hasn't had accessible and that's because
a lot of things play that part religion
location the fact that she's not social
as much so the places and things that
she does in order to attract that person
who's ideal is not going to be as
accessible as a general thing so that
was just my yeah no no I understand what
you're saying I just I think this is
just my opinion that a lot of times we
would be helped as women if men were a
little more honest with us and usually
if we're single by a certain age there's
there's a reason yeah because like men
will find like an eight or higher that's
fit feminine friendly mental font
they'll like sniff them up they'll
she'll go to the grocery store and get
like you yeah I mean you can all think a
girl right and I think a lot of times we
live in delusion past a certain age
because nobody will be honest with us
because they're trying to protect our
feelings I love a lot of that is a lot
of things that do happen that does
happen often yeah not all the time yeah
sorry to his sister anyways anyways uh
Christine what do you think I mean two
things come to mind for me really I mean
the answer everyone's pretty much given
as to single by choice is that the
options aren't available well that's not
really by choice then is it because if
the option was available then you
wouldn't be single and the second thing
is I think you attract what you are so
if the options aren't available I do
think that that's an indication that you
perhaps are shooting too high and you're
not acknowledging where you are and what
you bring to the table because I'm a
very firm believer that we always
attract what we are in life and if the
options available to you are not what
you like
that's not the world's problem I think
that's your problem
what do you this single by choice what
do you think
[Music]
the environment as well because for
maximum I would take myself as an
example like for example I'm keeping
myself for marriage and I'm gonna be
single for a long time because in this
generation sex is everything are you a
virgin yeah oh you are yeah I am okay
and so how I'm just shocked yeah no no
one is in this day and age
um and so you feel like that's kept you
single yes okay that yeah it's just that
if there's nothing else
yeah there's not no room for improvement
anywhere
oh yeah I have to improve on certain
things for myself but personally I think
that's one of the main things that will
like make me single okay yeah even if
that's the point I was making is that
your answer is that it's the environment
and it's not you and I think I'm not
saying I know anything about you right I
don't however I do think it's our own
responsibility to take accountability
for our own circumstances so if you
don't like the circumstances you're in
which I don't know if you do I'm just
saying hypothetically if you don't like
the circumstances you're in
I don't think blaming the environment is
a way to change that I think in fact
blaming yourself and perhaps recognizing
in yourself maybe I'm not doing all the
things I could be to attract what I want
I think that's a better route to
actually getting what you want than
saying oh it's because of this reason
and that reason and oh our paths aren't
aligned I I don't I personally don't
believe in that and I think if you want
something in life the way to get it is
by changing yourself it doesn't depend
on anything else around you I understand
I'm not blaming the society or anything
like I'm very happy to be single to be
honest like it's not something that is
not a priority for me to like find a
husband and get married is I would love
to get married like I wouldn't mind
getting married like young but it's not
a priority for me I rather like work on
myself do what I want to do and and I
know at the same time that I don't
necessarily project that like you would
never think that I'm you know like
vision and stuff so I know maybe I do
like I don't track my type
well yeah it's not really a priority for
me to be honest I feel like if I meet
someone and the person understand my
point of view but doesn't that explain
your whole situation you've just said
that it's not a priority and that's why
you're single yeah
the fact that you've just said that you
put um you know you said like finding
yourself first and yeah right so that's
that's you putting yourself at the top
and then putting marriage and kids if
you want children second because if you
put them at the top chances are you you
probably at least be on route to having
that already
so what do you think I should do to be
on top to find the house oh I I don't
know if it's what you want in life I'm
saying if what you want in life is to
find yourself and do whatever first and
chances are that's what's gonna happen
what I'm also highlighting is that if
that then does happen well you might
then get that and then decide well I
want the marriage and kids and
everything but by that time that happens
you might have already shortened your
chances because of what we were saying
earlier about what men generally is a
rule find attractive in a woman
obviously you have the fact that you're
a virgin massively on your side but
that you know your Youth and your
fertility by the time you found yourself
chances are that's not going to be as
Prime as it could be I don't think I
should be like running for that like I
should have been running for a man like
looking for that because I need that
it's not like for me we all need a man
I'm sorry I don't know if you agree with
that but for me we all need a man but
that doesn't stop me from living my life
and I feel like me and the right person
will come at the perfect time I
shouldn't like wait or like be like okay
now I'm 24 like I'm 23. so so I have I
have a stat for you they're predicting
that in our age demographic half of us
are going to be single and childless
never have children
damn so the data isn't backing up what
you're saying that most women it's just
going to happen for and that we have to
do nothing to get the men that we want
because that's essentially what you're
saying you're saying I should work on
myself and you're like there's no what
we can do for them it's always what can
we do for ourselves I definitely I
definitely believe that you do attract
that what you said your circumstances
and the things that you're ready for and
the things that you admit and put out
there are things that will be attracted
to you at some point in time because
that's what you're going after so that
has a big part to play with a lot of it
so a lot of the single women who say
that I'm happy with being not single is
and and put in it as a second thing on
their list that would obviously hinder
the chances of being in a relationship
because I'm saying because the energy
ain't even aligning for that to happen
yeah I'm saying so that is an agreeance
to what you said earlier but I agree but
what she's saying as well is you have
cultural factors as well that make it
for a woman to be difficult to go for a
man like from my culture we're gonna
wait for them to come for you so even
it's going to depend on the environment
that that's where I agree with you it's
going to depend on the environment I'm
living in for me to alert right but the
best women have been coming for them all
the time exactly you know I I have a
friend um I'd probably rate her like
eight nine and no matter where she goes
it's like
yeah she got married young oh my God
yeah she was because she she was you
know she was the ideal right like you
know so what's the idea
um fit so I would say look up your BMI
and if you're not your BMI then lose
weight yeah I mean it all starts there
right if you're not you can't you can't
say you carry if you're overweight you
can't say you care what men want because
that's the first thing they look for is
is weight
um I'd say like femininity so you know
um I I think especially Christian guys
want a woman that's going to obey them
and serve them and I think yeah and a
lot of women in the church really they
they don't do that they preach this like
Mutual submission thing the like which
which isn't even true it's not biblical
it's propaganda they put in the church
to basically leave the women single so
they can just donate for a lifetime it's
really it's really sad if you look into
the roots of it
um yeah I mean fit feminine friendly I'd
say it starts there you know Kevin
Samuels right chip left yeah so what
feminine in front of XXX yeah I mean
Kevin Samuels was goaded for a reason
right
um yeah and so I actually I don't think
there's a such thing as single by choice
I think it just means I think it's like
women we create these words that don't
mean anything yeah and to like to like
whenever something bad happens to us we
just seem to make up words to make it
like sound nicer
so when the truth is right when we're
single The Men We want don't want us
right sure it's it's we don't like the
way
I'm gonna I have a whiteboard for this
real reason yeah let's go
so
we turn on
can we turn on this one yeah okay it's
not so this is my thought our our modern
women really single by choice so we have
now this is the this is the I'm gonna
put some nice hair
yeah this is the Modern Woman a nice
modern woman right now she usually has
Instagram does anyone hear not of
Instagram
no no okay everybody's got an Instagram
okay
now she's also goes you know do you who
goes out to eat here or anyone all right
so she also goes to get food let me
should I I'm just going to draw a plate
I know people are gonna
I can't draw okay so she goes and so
maybe she'll go to the grocery store
this is like a cart you know
okay please please bear with me and then
she might she might go to the gym which
is here's the gym there's a door
yeah okay so she goes to all of these
nice places right and you know then the
Modern Woman has about like 50 guys
messaging her on Instagram then another
guy might go it like you know talk to
her at a restaurant who's here has been
approached on Instagram who's gotten a
message yeah everybody okay who here has
gotten a message on on at dinner yeah
okay who's gotten approached at the gym
right okay so the Modern Woman is really
getting approached everywhere now
there's different types of guys
approaching right so we have Bob Joe
now these three guys are approaching
everywhere now this is um we're gonna
call him
um option A we're gonna actually know
I'm gonna make him option C
C B A that's the quality now a man is
the best right now hey man
if he approached the Modern Woman she
would say yes she's be excited right but
he wants
the traditional hottie
what do you want me do you do you think
you appear to be a traditional woman
I don't know yes
no you are but you don't appear to be
okay
um I I would say you're not a
traditional Woman based on your mindset
now this is a now and I'm going to tell
you why okay okay I'm gonna tell you why
I think that traditional Women Believe
by and large the family comes first and
they live their life this way
traditional women really are married
before the age of 25 I don't claim it's
me okay I just say the truth these are
we gotta you know as women we gotta
admit like who is the best we gotta say
who is the ideal right just like men can
say LeBron James is the ideal basketball
player I think as women we should come
together and say that chick that's the
ideal woman right and the ideal woman
puts Family First in her primary
reproductive years so they're usually
married before 25 and they typically
um believe in obeying and serving a Man
based on the words you said which is
that you wanted to focus on yourself
that puts me above the family and that
puts you in the modern category no well
you know um because I feel like I don't
know if you can hear me yeah I feel like
for the family one even if you're not
married into 25 I mean
even if you're a rent a rotated family
that's just settling
well this is that's a very modern
mindset now traditional women are happy
and grateful to have a man but modern
women modern women think they're
settling when typically the man is above
them now I'm gonna I'm gonna give you
guys I'm gonna tell you why men nowadays
are better than women to go back to what
you said I believe there is such thing
as a modern traditional woman I think
there's that's a new word that women
made up because they don't like the way
it sounds
yes yes I think that no no because I'll
qualify myself as that yeah which one
because I put family first I had a child
very early so I did focus on my child
first okay before but did you did you
stay with the dad no okay
no no now you're here single mothers
what ended it what ended what ended yeah
it was not a traditional man okay no no
no no no like what who did you break up
with him yeah okay see that was my
feelings above my family no it was my
son's feeling oh no how old was your son
okay so the two-year-old broke up your
marriage they did he did it okay okay
no I think that like you don't like the
way it sounds right okay how how is he
not traditional it was not traditional
because first of all I was a provider
okay I was the one going to school and
provide for the family okay what did he
do what did he do okay why why did you
pick a guy that does not have a job we
were young that's what I'm saying okay
so again again let me go back to Modern
women pick men without jobs because
that's what they qualified
okay sorry I mean I don't think this
shouldn't be crazy
it shouldn't be it shouldn't be crazy
that we get what we qualify foreign
let's break this down how else would you
know what you qualify for at least time
I didn't know I was 18 years old okay
and at 18 years old you know there's
women that marry rich men of course and
you married a broke man I was I was
around what I knew so so
let me break this down let's go back to
it so these were the offers that were
coming to you and it was broke men yeah
now some 18 year olds
some 18 year olds I know 18 year olds
right that get marriage offers from
Richmond yeah so the only common
denominator here is that you are
a modern woman it's okay
I did it so now now here's the thing
traditional women take accountability
modern women no I can say based on this
conversation I fully take accountability
but at the end of the day okay of course
there isn't the environment as well that
you grew up in okay let's let's talk
about the environment
traditional women so so there are
traditional women right that grow up
that start off they grow up in a bad
environment right but they seek out
wives and don't get pregnant out of
wedlock and don't make any of those
stupid choices no offense no but they
don't marry the broke men or have kids
with the bro I I think maybe you should
just say the marriage because you like
you were trying to defend well we
weren't married and I'm like is this
this is worse you know so that's like
that's like more moment okay this is
worse that's why I've asked you do you
believe a such thing as a modern
traditional nope that was the question
no no I'm giving you the answer so yeah
no I think this is this is Stacy she's
the ideal okay
okay so now that's the other thing
modern Women Believe In Love wow now
traditional no women don't believe in
love they believe in traditional women
I really don't agree yeah so traditional
well that's probably because you're a
modern woman
okay now traditional women believe what
is what is a wife let's start there
where's the wife
my wife is someone that was super her
husband okay cook take care of her
husband be submissive yeah she she obeys
right now is it obeying your husband to
leave
right I wasn't my husband no technically
like your boyfriend whatever well but
that was the situation you picked I feel
like even though
I understand you a little drawing but
you just don't like it
but it's kind of like the old master of
our parents when they will suffer in
their marriage and they would still stay
because they're obeyed and we know our
values now okay so I'll tell you what
happened where where so France
were your parents traditional super
traditional okay did your mom tell you
things no no okay so your mom I'm just
wondering where is this coming from that
the parents were unhappy if your moment
like not for my family okay I've seen
definitely like parents where they fight
and stuff and okay the woman was thicker
and stuff okay well if they fight
typically that's the woman's fault okay
I'll give you an example where is it
where is another okay let me let me give
you an example where is somewhere that
you also have to obey I work okay now if
you're fighting with your boss is that
more reflective on the boss or the
employee
because if I if I have the ball okay
okay I'll give you an example I'll give
you an example uh King over there if I
say to King hey King turn on the camera
and then he starts arguing with me
that's probably a fault on the employee
because he wasn't listening right it
depends on the situation no I don't
agree because
do you want to hire an employee that
says I'm only going to listen to you
when I feel like it because it depends
that depends let's say you said at eight
every day that the cameras must be
turned but you come at 8 15. so
basically it's really your fault because
you're late but she's about eternity
yeah okay
but it didn't argue you just well and
then if I say hey King can you turn on
the camera and then just put it on oh
exactly now this is the that also goes
back to it doesn't become an argument
unless the woman doesn't listen
and that's a and that's right modern
women modern women let me let me break
it down modern women think they should
obey when they feel like it traditional
Women Believe in and they'll say words
like it depends well what does it depend
on how she feels that's the truth of it
but go on go on I'll answer your
question I'll answer nah this is too
much go ahead Yeah so basically the old
school traditional woman the old school
traditional woman is of what you are
explaining yes yes that is the oh the
one who would obey without
cause or without question the one who um
has family first and will do everything
and anything to make sure that her unit
of
2.4 is kept together yeah yeah that's
the old school so yes modern is the flip
side where a lot of the other things
come into play I.E
conditional I will only obey if and if
he does this then I won't do that kind
of thing that's the modern way of things
now
it's hard not to say there's a modern
traditional woman it's hard not to say
that based on the fact that you could
have come from an era where you have
Traditional Values and traditional
idealisms that you would go towards but
you live in a modern era where you are
obviously going to be influenced by the
environment and things that you consume
and the things that go on in life this
is fun no this is what I this is what I
call a Rebrand but yeah I just speak
realistically to the situations at hand
so this is a realistic representation
okay I'll give you an example I'll give
you an example so here's girl three
now she's not as bad as girl one
okay
right now over here maybe she's
got only fans she slept with you know I
mean but like over here you know she may
be now she's almost worse because you
know she was raised and taught right
but still chose
wrong wrong
though because you're talking about the
women right here okay okay how about
judging them in okay so well I'll go
back to we could
that's a whole other topic but I can't I
can talk about traditional men but I'll
say I pick wrong and right maybe I I a
better way to say it is what works and
what doesn't work we're more modern than
ever women have more Choice than ever
and women have been running
relationships into the ground
terrible yes why um because a hundred
years ago we were all married everyone
got married and they stayed married 85
percent of women were virgins on their
wedding day you know and and that's the
problem so yeah we now see the default
this is why I know you're moderate
because you keep asking about happy I
don't think it's how about happiness is
about the fact that nowadays the women
have to adapt to non-traditional men the
women yeah okay let's talk about let's
talk about okay so now this is uh women
modern women accountability is
Kryptonite so whenever I point another
negative about the women we have to
bring it on the map also about what you
were saying about how women have had to
adapt to non-traditional men yeah I
think someone said that women have to be
more masculine than ever before
I agree but we chose this we did the
suffragette movement women's equality
women's Liberation we chose this so now
we lay in the bed that we made no I
fully agree what you're saying by the
end of the day that's what I'm saying is
like have to put in perspective the fact
that the men nowadays
let's talk about let's talk about the
man okay what is a traditional man to
you what does he have to do yeah yeah
okay provider a leader respectful okay a
leader Edition Mako or what a decision
maker yeah okay loyal all right
I don't think that will ever be loyal
okay okay so provider leader loyal what
else good looking
really really they say a respectful
leader are most of the leaders
respectful no I just okay fine
respectful we'll put it down modern
women sorry okay go ahead what else what
else
okay
now
sorry this is
okay now this is gonna be Bob here
so the average man
makes more than the average woman
and the way that relationships break
down modern relationships
um women
it's about 20 25 the women don't work at
all
okay and that you know and then about
half both work but the women the man
still makes more than the woman
so about 75 per percent of relationships
and women retire sooner so a woman might
work for 20 years which I think is fair
because we used to work on farms and
that was a lot harder Google a day in
the life of the Amish women want this
soft life it's not traditional soft life
is not traditional we got to get that
out of our heads but okay so the average
man makes more money than the average
woman
so provider check
what if a woman makes more okay okay
exactly I can't check that because why
today now Society men expect half half
on everything
okay um but let's let's talk about let's
talk about once they get into
relationships that lead to marriage and
children 75 percent make more than the
women
okay so I have a question I have a
question if let's say we're selling a
car
okay let's say we're selling a car right
here we have a nice car
and they we go to these buyers over here
and we say hey well you want to buy this
car
and he says no
I don't want to buy that car do we
improve the car or do we blame the buyer
well okay so if all the buyers come by
and they say we want to go half we don't
yeah we don't want to pay a hundred
percent for that not good enough for us
what do you do we improve do we blame
all of the buyers or do we blame the car
so why is this hard for women to do
other way no I don't get an example
okay okay I'll break it down even
further so I'm selling a car right let's
just say I I had a Honda Civic growing
up so I'm just gonna say this is a nice
Honda Civic and I put I put my Honda
Civic on Craigslist and all of the men
are on Craigslist which is dating apps
right or whatever Instagram the store
all those places we had before and they
all say I don't want to pay for that do
we blame the men of course okay or do we
blame the car I'm gonna blame the car
you could mock it more okay okay well
what if what if other cars were getting
bought what if we had a nice Ferrari
here
and the Ferrari was getting bought
as in we're not good enough for our men
to provide completely for us but it's
not up to us it's about the cost of
living anyway exactly
okay see it's so interesting how we can
never it's always everyone else okay
let's go with the cost of living so what
we actually have is a lifestyle problem
most women will not go down in lifestyle
to have a family
they feel very entitled even though most
women are below average most women would
be thrown out a hundred years ago yup
our great great grandfathers would look
at all the women in this room and say no
no thank you I'm good because back then
they had fit feminine friendly virgins
that was it true but if you want to be a
good woman as I said it would trust in a
woman that you want to support her
husband with the cost of living you want
you don't want your husband to be
suffering so you're going to be
providing as well not as much as him no
they're going to help provide well even
traditional women used to work on the
farm they didn't sit and do nothing so
you just at a modern level now no no I'm
saying the only difference most modern
women do have good jobs and working a
lot of women yeah
no I'm only like 15 only only in 50 50
relationships only like 10 percent of
women out earn the men in the like 50 50
type and only fought like five six per
these are rough but it's like five six
percent of women are the primary
Breadwinners so women are not providing
this idea that these women are what go
ahead if you are the primary Breadwinner
well then I would ask why can you not
attract somebody higher than you but
it's all about access and it's where you
live your environment no it's okay okay
so if love is in in perspective well I
love that person what do you mean go
ahead no
well
um I think men love women don't
we do okay I could agree with that yeah
because because women women do you see
like your first response is never I
haven't heard you say a single character
trait that makes a man a good man I've
only heard provider she to so so to me
this says that like our heads are kind
of in the wrong places I was I was
literally going to say like we've been
doing this show how many shows we've
done so many shows and every time we ask
this question
we haven't had one single woman say the
character of the man but we wasn't asked
the character though yeah it was a
loaded questions
what do you look for in a man and you do
have to say
provider before character you could have
said character if that was important to
you I said respect
respect has nothing to do with character
he has no being a leader has to do if
your character anyone can respect you
temporarily to get in your in your pants
but if you look at the character of a
man that tells you all about him no
because respect goes he's doing
different ways he's like I can respect
you because I see the way you respect
other people when I'm around you
and then you're being
very to everybody around around me but
not to me then I will not go for you
because you're going to be disrespectful
to everybody not to me I'm not listening
to my point my point is you look at the
character of the man meaning you cannot
judge the character of a man by one date
of course no my point is these days most
relationships start at a date and
usually end in the bed within the next
couple of days that's not everyone
that's everyone
but because of who no listen so if
that's how much relationship go that
means that most women are not vetting
men I have to disagree with that because
of who what you don't think that women
control access to sex no they do but
it's the man that's gonna try to do that
like and it's the woman
and and the man can try all he wants
it accept yeah he's the one he's the one
trying so how's it the girls fall no no
he's trying he says it will be helpful
if she allows it yes that's ultimately
what it is his job is literally to try
to have sex with women 100 because the
man's job is to procreate that so it
doesn't matter if that's the factful
about it if he wants to try it on the
first day or on the 90th day it doesn't
matter it is his job to try and have sex
with a woman it is your job to secure a
commitment before letting him having to
have sex
all right
and my question would be and we go back
to and we go back to what why are you
attracting those type of men if if broke
50 50 men are attracted here's what
you're attracting why are you attracting
it it's probably because it's not that
good of a car
yeah
I know I know now I just disagree
what else could it be okay that's just
not for the person the men that approach
you might well in in my
um experience they're just not I don't
find them attractive and the ones that I
that I do the few they've got a lot of
options so they'll probably cheat
right so maybe it's okay so so isn't
that you acknowledging that you're
setting that own boundary on yourself
because you're making the requirement
that you want a man who doesn't cheat
you're not willing to go for the men who
won't cheat because you want them the
men that does have options no but not
okay the minute I have options but they
could still have options and still be
loyal yeah they could but chances are
the men who have options they're less
likely to be less likely to be let me
but then you should be secure with
yourself to know that you're good enough
so whoever's with you is not going to
decide to do that so anyway stop selling
these dreams sir let me let me break
this down for you a part of the problem
you're part of the problem I'm gonna I'm
gonna go away please stop I just no
offense I just you know this isn't true
you you know okay so let's these are
these are the men I'm gonna show you
what's going on in the daily market and
the reason I know this is because I've
done again hundreds of shows
um I've interviewed hundreds of people
and also
um dating apps will will back up what
I'm saying
so
now we have the women and the men that
date each other
okay
all right so these are the the provider
top dogs all right and the problem is
right now is that they are
everybody exactly that's the
problem no no no no let me let me let me
and I'll tell you no the problem is that
these women
are delusional enough to think these
moment here and here are delusional
enough to think that they deserve this
and this when really they deserve this
yeah so the the point is if the men that
are are if the you know and even those
guys there I really do believe there's
sometimes this is selling a dream a
little bit
um but there's occasionally a girl hot
enough to get one of these guys to be
faithful occasionally not really they
have too much but you know
um
the so you know the real problem is we
all just think we're better than we are
and if I ever imply that maybe we're
here here and here because most people
are average then the blame always gets
put on these guys
and you're co-signing this I don't like
it but you know this is what's going on
right that does happen yeah in the
modern day yes yeah I'm saying because
the more than they what we're being fed
and what is going on in our vision and
everywhere and what everyone's doing and
what's lit and what's hit to society
right now is mingling dating partying
drinking just doing all of this stuff so
therefore it's going to put everyone in
that mindset of everything is just one
big order so so now now what we're doing
is we're putting it on the men and the
women when really
only these guys are participating these
guys down here are not partaking they
can't so really it's all the women
partaking in this a couple of guys so
it's really more on us
what you said is because we value
ourselves more that's the reason why
we're going we're thinking that we
deserve better than what we are yeah but
what is an inverse and a woman is like
devaluing yourself because she does not
realize a worth well I would say that in
2023 we're pretty much worthless yep and
I'm gonna tell you why I'm gonna tell
you why I'm gonna tell you why now um
all right there's what you're speaking
about
have you got a child no kids no kids and
that's my choice that that's yeah it was
by the choices that I made every every
place I am in life is my own fault and
my own choice
okay we don't look it look it they're
not and this is the funny thing this is
like a gut reaction and I know this
because I've done so many shows when you
don't like the information I'm saying
then it's like Pearl what about Pearl
what about you what about you guys we
have to understand the person who's
speaking these things no no I'm telling
you it's it's what I've seen from
hundreds of shows and I really I I do
keep my room what 100 of them shows but
what's the panel
okay so so we're gonna go back to oh I
forgot what was the question now you got
me off topic
oh oh yeah
um so basically basically okay so what
what is makes a woman valuable
what makes a woman why are this oh why
women are worthless in 2023 and the way
I look at this is not in 2023 standards
I look at history okay okay so why
2023 chicks
are worthless you're gonna agree with me
in two seconds you won't say it but
you'll know I'm telling the truth now
okay what do men typically want
let's start let's start youth men like
younger women
um apps show that at about 22
ish sometimes 18 so really 22 but I'm
gonna say 18 just you know would be nice
um is when we Peak so 22 is one where
the hottest after that you're less yep
um so then then they want Purity okay
what they're showing is that one out of
three of us has an STD one out of four
of us or no no sorry one out of three of
us is an STD one out of three has gotten
an abortion okay
um and the average partner count is like
five to eight
what happens when you've slept with five
plus people
you actually have a 20 chance
of being a happy marriage
so that means there's an 80 chance that
you are done finished you're going to be
divorced or miserable yep eighty percent
chance if you slept with this many
people okay so we don't bring Purity to
the table
um now let's see Purity Youth and
Fitness right come on you you agree with
this right
yeah I just agree but so so African
culture the fitness as you said is no
I've had so many African men on myself
that's not true he's from Nigeria
okay okay no he's in West Africa I was I
literally moved to UK in 2019 whenever
people talk about Africa it always makes
me laugh because you guys don't know
what you're talking about I know I was
born in Africa
this nonsense I'll tell you the reality
is most of the women that claim that
they are now big and they are married
all of them were fit before they come
100 I agree let me make my point they
get into marriage and then they get fat
that's what usually happens now what if
you go and look at all our mothers go
and look at your pictures when they're
all in Union
so you want to say that the African
culture the real African culture will
say that a woman has to be fit
yes no that's not true no that's not
true African the African what African
men are attracted to is curves curves
yes curves is not fat I'm not saying
about fat what is it but what are you
talking about Fitness like proper
Fitness
belly no that's not true I disagree of
course it can be fitting curvy come on
girls
if you think I'm seeing is yeah the
African culture but I'm not going to be
fat but they're not going to be fit as
well
a bit chubby that's not true that's true
you look up that's not true no I
disagree I would say look up your BMI
and if your BMI is over then no you're
not in the you're not in that category
but again
look it um okay so now we're gonna go
and also why are you arguing for Africa
when you're in England
like you're in England there's there's
lots of black people sitting here so at
the end of the day so what I'm saying is
if you have to understand about the
cultural background as well after
England after England I think I've had
the most like African people on my show
like African view guys come on my show
all the time he has to be a factor they
no it's not well
I have a guy from you don't date women
and I determen and most of the guys I
know that we all grew up in Nigeria we
we all talk about these things how can
you tell us what look like in women
okay actually you know what I will tell
you why this happens like why she
believes this
um because here's a guy right here and
he sees
a fat chick okay
and he'll tell her what she wants to
hear and to get laid that's the problem
so it's not because they they will
have sex with the fatties but they're
not going to marry him I don't know he's
possible it's possible but not likely so
okay but like let's okay so let me let
me go back to let me go back to why
women are worthless in 2020.
[Laughter]
hey you know why they always default to
that um argument of yeah there's a fat
woman that got married is because the
reality is if you actually look at it
most men that tend to marry fat women
usually it's just like the same
situation we're talking about those are
the options that they had
when
when they have the most option they
don't pick fat women actually you know
what let's go back to the car analogy
okay so let's go back to so here's it
now let's go back to the car I haven't I
have an idea so this is the car this is
like the equivalent of a fat chick this
is um uh 200 000 mile Honda Civic and
these are the suitors that come and the
and the buyers tend to be broke because
it's got a lot of miles and it's big so
no oh so that's not I look it I'm not
even saying this about you I'm saying I
look it all of the men that have come on
the show and that event said they like
bigger women are are broke yeah yeah
okay
it's always subjective but the majority
of men I ideally would not want to fight
you well my question is where is
Leonardo DiCaprio all of the men with
the most options where is their fatty do
you think no okay oh come on let's go
let's go look at
actually get married to skinny girls but
I actually love fat girls for sex yep
but they don't want to be seen in public
yeah because why because narration
because the chick doesn't make them look
good on their arm they make them look
low value that's what because you you're
supposed to represent the guy the same
way if I dress like a bomb it makes my
guy look bad it shows and the other
thing you're not taking into account so
let's do Fitness because that helps with
children fat chicks have way more
complications they have a harder time
getting pregnant so if a traditional man
wants children he can't pick a fat chick
because guys you might not know that he
they think like this even the chubby
girls they might they might think okay
she's got a good shape but the way men
think is they're like all right she has
a kid she's going to put on like 20 and
she's gonna be gone so that's why it's
like they're like okay if she's already
chubby in her 20s what is that what is
that how beautiful is you yeah then I
have a lifetime of
you know
American a lot of women don't take into
consideration is the fact that men
actually not stupid we actually think
about a lot of things
if we pick a fat woman she's more than
likely to pass down those traits to our
children
men think about these things you know
oh one second this is so nah because
yeah because if the lady is overweight
and she consumes a lot of food and her
lifestyle is overweight but she has a
and she has a child then the child is
going to adapt that kind of mechanism
hence why you'll see a little chubby
cute baby it's not about genetics no
genetics has a big part to play as well
if there's obese mother then the the
genetic of that obesity can pass through
to the child so we're talking about fat
obese though no no no just general so
what's the qualification of fat roll
we're talking about right now BMI BMI
okay but it's not always accurate but we
get the BMI but either way it's just
about Aesthetics yeah it's not
ideally what the men would want as first
choice yeah
exactly so therefore or what the
argument is is that the fitness aspect
of this is you have to take
accountability for not being chosen if
you're not at that BMI this is the point
when we're talking about women settling
before the reason why most men would
eventually marry apartment because men
tend to settle men are more realistic if
they look at their situation and they
see okay you know what I've been out in
this market I've tried my best I've
tried to get men would settle but women
look at certainly like this oh yes we're
in jail now we we've lost in life it's
crazy that's true men do settle way more
than women yeah and and we could see
that because modern women are worthless
so let me go back to this so okay so
okay Fitness right
um now can we can we look up a king of
what a five six girl is supposed to
weigh
let's see the average height is like
five six so we're gonna we're gonna get
that children so the average amount of
kids a guy gets is maybe two two kids
it's actually I think it's lower than
that I think it's oh I think it's like
1.5 so let's let's let's go down 1.5
Beauty all right so I mean that's that's
pretty self-explanatory you have 1.5
kids because it's like average yeah
everywhere yeah so she might have one or
two you know one two kids
um what you you find it King
he'll he'll get it in a second so I'm
going to start with I'm going to start
with youth all right our average bride
is 31 years old
that is for even the fact that 35 year
old no offense but 35 year old women
think they qualify for marriage is crazy
why would a guy marry a 35 year old
chick
you know okay so we're gonna get there
in a second wait put it down put it down
what is BMI yeah so so
31 years so men prefer 22 we give them
31. men prefer
virgins
only four percent of women are virgins
on their wedding days congrats you still
have that that puts you above a lot you
know
um
Fitness the average woman is 170 pounds
which is ridiculous that is so fat and
five five that's ridiculous that's
ridiculous that's so fast
now now let's put up what we're supposed
to weigh yeah let's go what are we
supposed to weigh 5'5 is supposed to be
122 to 150 pounds but men have been
wanting to get laid so much they've been
lying to us about what's going on please
could you do yeah yeah sorry
we'll go kilogram yeah thank you
there we go so five five six you're
supposed to be five 53 to 64. basically
what yes yeah yeah yeah you know five
seven
um 55 5 8 57 yeah so we gotta they say
the best the best um they say that the
best uh dating coach for women is a
personal trainer
guys would you say that's true the best
dating coach for women a personal
trainer as it has a lot of benefits yeah
yeah
now now let's go let's go so you know
the average woman a hundred years ago
used to give them seven kids
the average woman 100 years ago was like
120 pounds
not 85 percent of women were virgins a
hundred years ago the average bride was
22.
so yeah I would say based on history and
what men have always that's why I said
we'd all be thrown out a hundred years
ago pretty much yep
um so this all of these statistics
from past time to now yep a lot of it is
based on the transformation and
transition of our culture cultural input
and media is I think about six I don't
know how much to say maybe but men's
requirements are still pretty much the
same because biologically we haven't
changed I get what you're saying but
I'll be the same but then as well you
see that you see that the requirements
are still the same their requirements
are the same but are they the simple but
for them
providers yeah but it's just that most
women want so much that their money
doesn't provide like my dad for example
is just an average working-class man he
he makes the average salary in the UK
and he's always been able to provide for
me and my mum my mum doesn't work but
that's because my mum doesn't get her
nails done every other week she doesn't
get her hair done everything so it's all
about what we're asking
besides
um also historically we said um
I've forgotten
but we're talking about okay and men are
men are no more the same no more the
same but historically most men have not
been able to reproduce historically only
40 percent of men have been able to
reproduce so the reality is
men have always never been
in a situation where all men would get a
chance to get a shot at this so when
women try to take dicks at men and say
oh this and that is actually you should
actually look at yourself and look at
the reason why you as a woman who
historically 80 of women have been able
to reproduce so if now you are not being
you are not able to reproduce as a woman
you should actually be looking at
yourself
the food choices we have now are
completely different which mess up a lot
of things the environment to eat those
things what's available what's available
there's organic and then there's crap
and most people work in class people can
afford the crap which messes up a lot of
things which happen internally that
we're not even knowing you can choose to
buy processed foods
I'm not talking about biological I'm
talking about most men historically
didn't even make the cut okay okay so
most men wear it rich enough or maybe
they were slaves or maybe for whatever
reason maybe they couldn't attract a
woman I'm not even talking about what
you're talking about so them saying Oh
men don't qualify men have always never
really qualified
but most women have and let's talk about
the culture who's in charge of culture
foreign
who's in charge of culture is who
whichever culture the person individual
is in their culture is in charge of how
they are okay but let's let's talk about
us women right we make 80 of consumer
buying decisions culture is literally
designed towards us because we make up
so much of the consumer buying choice so
most of our culture nowadays we can all
agree it's based on money you know we've
all been talking about cost of living
etc etc everything's based on money if
women are making most of the decisions
for where that money is going all of the
culture around us is going to be
tailored to women
exactly and so it all really starts so
let's let's talk about this
um the women as Christine so finally
pointed out
um we make the consumer buying decision
so all the companies are marketing
towards women so everything we see on TV
is because women like it the politicians
can't get elected because women you know
it's funny we're so not loyal that we're
not even loyal to political parties so
they'll just give us free stuff and
we'll vote for them
um so yeah women control the politicians
and women control the home because again
you know so many so many moms break up
with the husband and then they're in
control of the next generation of men
and women because they're in control of
the culture of the home or the dads will
be working more and who's in control of
the culture the women so if we're going
to blame the culture let's blame women
so basically but I don't listen to blame
in this well because um my my thing is
that something's always been like that
no it hasn't that's not true he also
just said it has not um what do you mean
settling as in like he said earlier the
men would never provide a fully but
girls were happy to get married to them
but now days okay like we just know our
values like what's talking about
if you know you can have someone that's
way better than it but do we know our
value or is our ego just over inflated
because of what we just said I don't
think if everything around us is
tailored towards us right women are
emotional creatures I hope we can agree
that we're emotional creatures so if
everything around us is tailored towards
us that means everything around us is
focused on our emotions how to make
women feel better so that's why I
suggest that perhaps it's that women
have an over-inflated ego because I mean
look around look at all this body
positive stuff it's telling women we
have more value than we actually do in
the eyes of men and that's why women are
saying well why am I not getting the man
I want because they're going for men
that they think they deserve because the
culture tells us that we deserve those
men when in reality we might not
let's let's talk about this so I have
let's talk about exchange what is value
all right let's talk about it let's talk
about okay because we always say women
women women are yeah let's we always say
we always say women are settling right
that's always what we say but the
average woman again is 170 pounds right
which is huge um yep fat yep
um 90 have been on birth control yeah um
slept with five to eight men which in
any other time period would be thrown
out disgusting and a hundred years ago
the men would be like that that is the
the town now now the men are like
five that's amazing but it's only
because we're in this time period okay
so so right now we have overweight
yeah that we're we're given to
the men saying
I am the prize
and I can't settle
when really so the real question is
um so okay and they'll say he doesn't
make enough to support oh sorry I think
I'm in the UK so it's 35k here
um but okay so he makes 35k
um
and what else protected he's still
stronger than her so he's still
protecting and
um so you know if a burglar breaks in he
has to die first okay so like right
right you guys all the men know this
right if you if a burglar breaks in if
we're if I live alone and a burglar
comes in suspended yeah exactly so we do
get protection and we do get 35k a month
now remember this is pretty good
considering in all other time periods
you would have been a peasant that's
what we would like to but I don't think
the men nowadays will be that type of
protector and provider anyway
um no money laying in the bed while the
dog gets back they're going to the front
never know what you feel they're gonna
make you push you forward and say go go
that's how I see them in nowadays yeah
well that is that's a better man that's
a holy that's a whole number that's
another debate yeah but if you see those
kind of men then you should actually be
looking I didn't said I was going for
them
that's the reason why I'm saying the men
are different that's the reason why the
woman settle for less or don't settle at
all history there have always been men
like that of course
people my point is if that is all your
sin then you is it you should actually
change your vision I didn't say that
because I said that's an example why
didn't I say that is all I see so the
one so then why are you are here
no but we were talking about okay okay
okay okay okay do you believe that the
majority of men would protect their
women if a bird okay so but you would
but the majority of women are overweight
and the majority of women would be
considered in any other time
period so you keep saying the men has
changed but who's changed more the man
or the women
who who changed first
that's a different question no matter
that I'm asking you see do you see you
see how women it's like as soon as an
answer makes us look bad we can't answer
it no it's not about look bad but it's
like I would like to understand why
women have changed first okay I'll tell
you why okay let's let's I'm so this is
such an educational show I like I mean
if we look at the exchange of value a
lot of women make more than 35k in the
UK
no they don't the majority of women do
not all my friends make more than that
that's what that's what most women will
say um but then you see you're saying
that men care about your money they
don't care
yeah I make a lot of money man don't
give a and okay then what do we
need them for they're not providing well
you see that's and I'm glad you said
that because it actually shows what I'm
gonna show next and I want you to I want
you to put that on a poster right there
what do we need men for I want I want I
want us to focus on that right there
telling on herself no offense but
so
here is the family okay so here is this
lovely family and it was in love and
this was like a hundred years ago okay
60 years ago
because I'm gonna go to a hundred
this all started a hundred years ago and
the woman said to the man hey honey hey
honey I want to vote
and the man said I don't know and a lot
of wives protested this they said women
we shouldn't vote but the men said okay
fine honey here is your right to vote
now the women get to vote
and so now 50 women or 55 percent of the
politicians so the politicians have to
pass now pass policies that benefit us
and not the men
and women
um said I want to work and the man said
all right honey fine you can go to work
right so now we get to we get to sit at
a desk and now we're working okay woohoo
um okay so then we get to work and then
the politicians come in and say ladies
ladies now that you're working
um why don't you guys let's put in some
policies that benefit you so what they
did was divorce that was for women
um child support
that was for women
uh me too so let me just accuse men of
raping me for no reason
um you know and the law will back you up
child support divorce me too and
um alimony
which shows that inherently women just
we are not good people I don't know why
because whenever you know she said what
do I need a man for
whenever women get leverage in a
relationship they make money they view
their men as useless and that is what
we've shown in history because women got
all this power and which was given to us
by the men and then we used it to break
up our families yup because for whatever
reason
um when women get money they don't use
it to benefit the family they use it to
benefit themselves yeah or the men and
the equivalent of that it's funny you
say that because what if a man got money
and ditched his wife
we would think that is terrible but what
if you're single if you're single it's
different well okay so let's talk about
you know we have had so much ground
today this might be my favorite show
I've ever done because you guys are you
guys are actually asking the good
questions so okay what do you make a
year
um
over 60k off the tax okay can we pull up
the delusion calculator
I think that would be the best step
going forward
what do you do for a living if you don't
mind me asking again yeah
she's gonna leave here she's like I want
to do that
um
so I'm gonna redraw these men
nice with the visual aid I just think
that the I just think the white board
like adds another level so you actually
exists a delicious yeah yeah so so
what's your age range of men you're
looking yeah go ahead so what's your age
what's your age range go ahead
um
25 to 35 okay
um what color I mean do you care oh that
makes rice okay
um I think that would be black in the
sense I'm interested in married men
and he has to be tall okay so
um and funny is it when you say mixed
like black and white I'm just yeah mixed
okay well I know I was gonna any color
or any race no she's saying next but I
think I think in the census if you're
mixed you put black if it's black and
white yeah so I think we can it doesn't
go that specific what
okay above six foot what about obese men
no okay
um how much does he have to make
over 40K okay okay 40K
so he can make less than you then I'd
prefer it to be more but that's the
minimum
I mean okay let's say let's say 50k yeah
yeah this is this is us but the numbers
are really similar in terms of like it's
not that different so 55 just put
because that's the equivalent roughly
all right what percent I want to start
what percent of men do you think fall
into those categories
um probably like 10 10 okay go ahead
so my question for you is do you think
you're in the 0.24 of women yeah you
think really you think okay who who's a
10 that's a 10. who is a 10 in Hollywood
you think you're as hot as Beyonce
the answer is not as hot as Beyonce okay
so so you're not so you're not a 10 then
I don't think I'm a tan okay so what do
we rate ourselves looks it starts with
looks for men in eight okay
um who do you think is an eight in
Hollywood
an eight I would say eight to ten means
you could model that you are like as hot
as models who's in who's innate in
Hollywood
um
I can't think of the top of my head okay
um Chris Brown Chris Brown No No a girl
looks white a girl a girl uh all right
what about uh I I feel like you're
you're an honest chick who's an eight in
Hollywood
uh
what Hollywood Hollywood a girl a girl a
guy
eight
I mean now I don't really know but I
would have said back in say the 90s
someone like Jennifer Aniston okay you
think you're as hot as Jennifer Aniston
as she was in the 90s yeah
okay then why where are your Jennifer
Aniston results
I'm telling you women that look like
Jennifer Aniston these the men find them
they're not so it's not that I don't
have options I've got options but I I
you know
exactly that's the point
he's so upset today
[Laughter]
I'm not even trying to be mean it's it's
there's a there's a term for it it's
called cognitive dissonance when you
can't relate reality with with what like
like literally your life literally gives
you all the answers but you for some
reason you you can't make those
connections and see where you need to
improve because you're you're either
lost in some fantasy or your you've
believed something about something that
has thrown you off what reality actually
tells you but do you believe that this
is still going to be a choice though
because let's say now yeah you I believe
the certain type of life that you feel
like because of the love that you lived
you can't improve yourself anymore or
improve yourself to the level of the
type of men that you want so that's the
reason why you choose to be by yourself
is it still not your choice here's the
thing the thing is that there's when it
comes to dealing with reality what a lot
of women don't know how to do is realize
that there's actually a ceiling for
everyone yeah of course so no matter how
much you want to improve some people
would never get nine results because
they are just not nice yeah that's what
I'm saying you know what you settle live
and improve and maybe be a six well I
don't think
or maybe not even improving at all most
people are fights because five is
average but when we hear average most
men understand this but a lot of women
have a visceral reaction to average
because they think it's such a bad thing
but most people are average and the
reason why you see people in Hollywood
usually when it comes to looks is
because they are well above average yeah
and go and look at most of the Hollywood
star stories a lot of them were found in
some Village somewhere
it's not even a thing where they were
all born in Hollywood no so it's
disconnected
but the question is
found in some hell now
Margot Robbie's from Australia and she
was one of them she was the neighbors
before she was in Hollywood I mean we
could what go ahead no King The King but
you still didn't reply to my question so
you don't you think it's a choice though
choice to do what the fact that you're
just single because you can't improve
yourself to a certain level so you're
just gonna
no it's it's not a choice I know you
know you've got the guy you wanted you
would yeah be single so it's not really
a choice your choices might lead you to
that final conclusion where you
eventually don't get any man but it's
not a choice you made I actually know I
actually I actually know an obese chick
that got a high value guy but she was
just she was just perfect wife she had
everything else it happens rare though
rare don't don't don't that's not a
dream don't put your eggs in that
but yeah so let's go back to the the
so here
here so these are the men that the the
women that these men would wife right
and they're still gonna cheat though
don't worry so they're still gonna
and the problem with the dating Market
is all of these chicks here that are
pretty much average they're really you
know and their whole life has shown them
that they're average and they're not
above average just average think that
they deserve this guy
who is um a Chris Brown level when
really
um these girls can barely get this guy
and if they were at this level they
would have a ring from those men
and yeah and I come but there's kind of
men at that level they don't they don't
work anyone I don't think okay let's
let's talk about those man thank you now
here's here's the problem
um women are living this what I call La
La Land
now this is again from hundreds of shows
where women think they think and they do
this in their 20s who here has had a
blue check mark message them God it's a
blue check famous Rich right oh nothing
nothing you've never met one
but I thought right but not Bluetooth
okay well not not Blue Tick okay
um well what did he do
um he's the founder of a tech companies
millionaire okay millionaire and what
what happened with him
um so we went on a few dates okay but it
didn't pan into yeah I'm not really
dating's not my top priority okay at the
moment okay now what I what I say is
these women are in la la land right
because typically again they think
they're here this is what they think but
this is where they are now La La Land
and they typically believe that these
men do not settle down and that is
typically because the only men they see
are celebrities not saying you but this
is just typically what happens
entertainers
um
Etc where really um the men that are
actually up here are pretty boring guys
like yeah it's not the exciting it's
like guys that really do the same thing
every day they work long hours they
don't even really have time to cheat I
mean they'll still find a way they'll
find time you know but but in general
they don't really have time to cheat
like that because they're working
12-hour days
um yeah and those men are actually more
likely to be married
yeah rich men marry more than poor men
yeah it's actually a rich person's game
so again if you're not getting marriage
from these men it's just typically
because you're not these women and I
don't think that's a bad thing I think
I'm an average chick I think most chicks
are average but the problem is
everybody's telling us we're not average
and I think it's okay to be average go
ahead King and another trap a lot of
women tend to fall into is like you said
when women start making money they then
think that their money adds value to
them in terms of what men look for when
literally it doesn't so you come into a
man's world the masculine world you
start making money and then you start to
think like a man which is a very big
problem now men when we want to attract
someone we're going to the world we try
to gather resources and that's how we
attract women but when you women come
into the man's world and start making
money you then start to think like men
and think that just because you've made
five million then now you deserve a man
that ends 5 million that's not how it
works
by being everything that's opposite to
that kind of woman that can earn 5
million
which are the Traditional Values yeah
and what goes back to what I call a cope
no fats no offense guys I'm gonna I'm
gonna write down things that you guys
have said this show but it's not about
you just you know I would have wrote
These written these down anyway
um I'm single by choice that's a COPE in
my opinion anyway
um
yeah code it's like it's like I don't I
don't like reality so I'm gonna what I
call cope it's just an excuse yeah an
excuse
um or
um it's my environment you know I just
don't
I'm not out there enough
when Instagram is very public it's a
very public place you can you can it's
like that's like a for sale sign but
that's where all the modern men that
they don't want are mainly no no not
true um I I mean a lot of modern men are
there but again I know people get
married off Instagram every day I
actually I know a guy
um he a girl messaged him and said I I'm
I he he slept with all of all of the
hoes all of the everybody and then when
he wanted to get married a chick
messaged him and said she was a virgin
she knew how to cook she knew this
um and he said if you can prove it I'll
marry you and he did now they have three
kids she did yeah right this is a you
know that scenario is it oh is it
that's not even though oh well my my
point is that the women that are
actually traditional get the traditional
guys
I've never had traditional women or how
can you be fully traditional nowadays
um I I have met traditional and no
traditional women and they never
complain about men not paying they never
complain about the dusty men in their DM
they never they never have a problem
because men are pretty nice to them yeah
how can you be traditional well it's
definitely harder especially as women
were so influenced by the culture that
we created
um
yeah I I would say you got to be raised
by traditional family and if you don't
and if you weren't to seek it out that's
what I would say
to find traditional women
you can usually go to churches I say
find some 70 year old ladies they might
be able to teach you something in
churches not the churches you know
nowadays like churches 100 years ago oh
the churches nowadays are terrible
exactly it's it's tough
of traditional things well my my point
is if there's a will there's a way but
typically women don't want to find out a
way to do anything we're just kind of
lazy so last thing don't always lazy for
modern and well like trying to provide
fossils um because we usually have cushy
jobs we don't want any of the hard ones
like we'll work in HR or marketing or
Communications but we don't do I don't
know build buildings we don't work on
oil rigs we do we do the easy jobs go
ahead
those part those points that you just
rubbed up the board in regards to the
reasons what we've said throughout the
show do you believe that none of them
have a factor in why women don't choose
to be single or do choose to be single
are you ruling them out like this is all
none of these have a factor to
play in the reasons why women are single
is that what your conclusion is my
conclusion is typically the reason women
are single is because they do not
qualify for the men that they want
because if the men that they wanted
wanted them we would be in relationships
and I think it's either you improve
yourself to get to that point
or go go a little down because also
recognizing the ceiling like a lot of it
isn't even to do with improving yourself
like there's you know you might be on
your Peak form but sometimes you know as
king said you just have to recognize the
ceiling because yeah and if you're still
you know if you think you're doing
everything you can to attract the kind
of man you want you're still not getting
him well you know well and Chris look
even increase your level even Chris
Brown will sleep with a five now and
then that doesn't mean you're on Chris
Brown's level you just slap yeah a lot
of you know and I think that's what's
creating the delusion is once women
sleep with a certain type of guy they
think they're that and ultimately it's
only us hurting us as well so you know
what we were saying about the the
culture you know and we picked all of
this and it's all of these companies
advertising to women the only people
it's really hurting by not recognizing
your own level and saying oh no your
value
because we're telling ourselves we
deserve more yes because I know my value
but in the end you're alone with your
wine and your cats and dying alone so
it's only us that it's actually hurting
all of this empowerment stuff is
actually going to be the end of us it's
nothing empowering about telling women
you know you're up here when you're not
that's not kind it's not kind to tell
someone there's something they're not
like would you tell an anorexic person
who comes to you I'm a real person by
the media nowadays is promoting that
they're saying that that's what we
should yeah yeah they're saying
I'm so glad you guys brought this up
yes I'm so glad the Sims because they
want so the Sims I'm gonna I'm gonna
draw you guys a simp man
so typically a simp man in the in the
man order let's go here I'm just gonna
do I'm just gonna do four men to make
this easier
he is typically so like if we're gonna
do four this guy is getting laid right
he's sleeping with the women this guy
the only way he gets to sleep with the
women is by telling them what they want
to hear
yeah so these are the men that say baby
I love fatties
these are the men these are the men that
say there's nothing wrong with my 37
year old sister that's still single nope
you know
um and I don't even think it's conscious
like sometimes I think they just repeat
things
um there's I love
horse
these are the men that co-sign all of
this and they're a real problem they're
this is like because again it's not as
you said it's not kind to lie to us so
I'd really like to encourage men to tell
us the truth
to the point it hurts our feelings
because I think we need it it's nicer to
have your feelings hurt in the moment
but still live in truth no the truth is
always the best than to be lied just
because in the moment it makes you feel
good respect
wow thank you thank you
and and the reality is so many men
actually shot out of the sexual
Marketplace that they are willing to say
anything just to get in
and this is what you guys don't realize
that's why women if you go on Instagram
right now go on any random girls page
you will see a whole flock of men
underneath their dropping comments that
that she would never ever pay attention
to why are they doing that because they
think that oh I might be the one she's
gonna pick
so imagine going on your Instagram every
day and you keep having
different random men telling you oh my
God you're beautiful the way you are you
are going to believe it you like no one
is
right so the point is this is for men
lying to us but this is this is the
issue the issue is a lot of so the
education has has just gone wrong from
the start so a lot of people grew up in
broken homes they didn't have directions
from their fathers they didn't have good
upbringing as I would call it so there's
already a break in transmission so the
thing now is part of the problem is on
top of that we now have women that have
so much of an ego that they are not even
willing to listen to the men that are
actually willing to tell them the truth
so for instance I give an example we've
done the show so many times we've had so
many different women sit on that couch
and I'll tell them something and then
you you can tell that the moment they
leave this door they're probably going
to be telling their friends oh that
there's this idiot guy and I was just
saying this
but the reality is I was telling them
the truth because I'm not really
interested in sleeping with them yeah
exactly yeah we're talking about the
fact that you're saying that was men
that was doing everything yeah so the
thing now is
ideally what you should start doing is
every time you hear anything that makes
you feel good actually try to ignore it
and start seeking out the things that
actually make you uncomfortable because
that is where you find the most growth
you can never grow without discomfort
that's why when you go to the gym and
you work out your body is soft yeah
because there's no growth without
discomfort but again still
well and it's funny because one thing we
talked about in this in this whole
discussion was taking accountability and
what did you guys do with what what did
what did you am I on am I on okay yeah
and what did you what did you guys do at
the end you said well it's the Sims
fault no I agree with everything like
you said about the fact that we are just
choosing what is available to us okay so
I'm gonna read some super chats okay but
I'm glad we're on the same page
um okay so Dr David Baker a 2023 survey
of thousands of men found that 65
percent would not even consider going on
a single date with an overweight women
either either lower your delusional
standards or lose some weight period The
Haven project the delusion is real most
of the female panel
um wait the delusion is real and most of
these female panels I've been losing the
will to live at this point I swear to
God
um Doug MPA the average woman in the UK
makes uh 25 000 pounds
Adam Sutton in the last 50 years the
average woman has gained 40 pounds the
average man has gained four
puffy Vegas I'm going to speak for all
black men across the world if you look
at the rich ones they date girls all of
my friends all of my high value black
men do not date women above a size eight
ninety free-toe pie it's not that
men want a super skinny woman for vanity
we think if there's a fire at home can I
carry her 300 pounds outside the door
um Wyda um as a Nigerian man no thick
madams please Doug MPI King producer
dropping truth bombs thank you King for
representing us Ben so well thanking
talking to single mom and a whale is
like talking to a wall uh puffy Vegas I
was born in 1974 and traditional
communities everything you're saying is
completely wrong women worked hard jobs
they were seamstresses Cooks
hairdressers to clean houses they owned
businesses I never seen get hit Dr David
Baker
um
today right now in the developed World
28 of women are involuntarily childless
no women aren't single by choice they
squander their 20s chasing careers in
men who won't commit to them ignoring
men on their level Thane Matra
VW Beetle saying it's worth a v it's a
VW Beetle car
oh Volkswagen okay Volkswagen Beetle
saying it's worth Bugatti money um Keck
not happening Adam Sutton marriage is
for children it's about Duty respect in
a family unit love as you believe in it
um a Madison Avenue falsehood that
leaves you on meds and single perks
single by choice for men is real I'm 38
6'3 and earn 50 000 pounds a year
slightly overweight but weight lift
however I won't ask any women out
anymore because of my history and how
modern women are mgtow Wida men control
access to relationships ladies if you
are not chosen it's because no man chose
you Doug MPA great to see Christine
Grace Smith on the panel
um sugachi uh men are the are The
Gatekeepers of commitment can be single
by choice women have no choice aside
from picking bad men and ignoring the
good ones I'm gonna refresh it real
quick guys also if you want a women
shouldn't vote sure if these panels
every day just make you think wow we
can't have these women
as leaders of the Free World we can't
put them back in the kitchen
by your women shouldn't vote shirt today
the link is in the description all right
um first coffee then air I'm stuck alone
because I'm neither six foot
I'm stuck alone because I'm neither a
six foot five percent man nor am I
willing to stamp I'm average but very
fit hard working but only five seven I
wonder how many other men are in my
position
King turn your mic up
um okay let me refresh it real quick I
think I'm done
okay
um can we show one of the whole math
um ones can we show the
what is comments from today yeah yeah
they just super them it's live so
um you wanna pick one
just pick one I thought they were both
good
they're saying my Super Chat reading
skills have improved thank you guys it's
only been a year and a half
sign
ladies
let me tell you this
after everything that you have been
through
the next man had better give you every
ounce of everything that he has this man
is a tuck enabler every ounce tucking is
a misguided response to hypergamy in
which the attempts to escape the
not people Zone by telling women that
they are perfect and that they deserve
even better
the hope is that in validating
delusional women they will see you as
having extra value
of course this tactic does not work and
sometimes it has even the opposite
effect but it remains popular among the
general population and internet
celebrities such as Destiny so then why
is tucking so popular well delusional
women love to be validated
when a cuck provides a mediocre woman
with validation she expresses Joy which
the then mistakes for sexual
interest
this creates a market for what I call
power cooking tucking with production
value
this encourages unwitting to
continue the validation cycle and dig
themselves even deeper and I have seen
power cooking before but I've only seen
it produced domestically
the foreign power cooking Market being
this strong is not a good sign at all
the other one too I think they're both
long shorts
mostly ho
hey
long shorts
Abby's perfect man
this is a four-part video explaining a
popular joke that women make on Tick
Tock to people who just don't get it
[Music]
morning Abby because if it was a good
morning you wouldn't be like this Abby
has described her perfect man I had to
write it down because it was a lot he is
a hot six foot five Mafia man who's
willing to spoil her and unalive other
men that is definitely a top man
there's just not a lot of gorgeous six
foot five murderers hanging around so in
female long-term mating strategy I drew
a Galaxy because it needs a lot of
unpacking but I would say just
estimation maybe a quadrant of that
Galaxy is composed of dark Triad
personality traits which Abby has made
important so the man you're describing
is a definite 10 very rare and you
didn't ask me so I won't give you a
number but I'll say above five somewhere
above average and uh your 10 is going to
have access to and interest in you know
pretty much just this whole range of
women here so you say you want him to
spoil you which is very clear you would
like to be in the keeper category which
could conceivably happen but a high
value men you know when you get up to
the 910 area they very commonly have
multiple Keepers and I don't know if
you're accounting for that in your
fantasy so I know that Abby was mostly
kinda sort of joking maybe probably but
if you are a man I just want you to know
that women are having these fantasies
and you are competing with them
in the comments for this video I was
greeted with the normal unhinged reality
denying responses including mainly it's
a joke
sometimes I Stitch a girl's video and I
analyze it and people respond it's just
a joke and then some other people will
respond yeah but every joke has a kernel
of Truth so I'm going to explain this
one what Abby said was morning but not
good morning because she was not waking
up next to a six foot five hot mafia
boss murderer who was going to spoil her
now every joke has one thing in common
and that is doing it wrong like it's
time for breakfast oh I'm using the
wrong end of my spoon
my spoon is too big that's not the
oatmeal spoon that's I know what is the
correct thing to do and I'm doing the
incorrect thing on purpose I know that's
not a great joke but it's an example
so in Abby's case the thing that she's
not supposed to be doing is
saying it out loud that's why her post
was so popular because all the women
know that all the women are thinking and
feeling this and you're not supposed to
say it out loud because then the boys
hear you
and that's why it's just a joke doesn't
mean it's not true
I then continued to provide examples but
I had to stop because I wasn't getting
anything else done
funny joke
that kind of like Abby's joke it was
kind of like exactly the same joke about
how that they want to be with murderers
you know what we should do we should
make a list let's just start a list of
girls who made the I'm in love with
criminals joke all right we got Abby and
then we have Pia
slash
and
everybody
well there it is again that famous
female sense of humor these girls just
keep writing the same joke about loving
murderers we go Julia
if you haven't watched my zones video
yet go see it now I'm laying it all out
for you women like bad boys and it is
not a personality defect it is a part of
their nature
I'm not saying women are bad I'm just
saying we all have needs left over from
the Stone Age and if they go unchecked
then things get crazy
yeah so what do you got what'd you guys
think the only thing I agree with what
he says is a woman like bad boys that's
it I don't
know you agree with that
why don't you agree because that's not
why I would like for myself but the rest
what I said is just yeah have you have
you had a boyfriend before yeah and what
what happened
it was what was he like
[Music]
okay so he was a quiet guy yeah and how
did it end
he ended because I couldn't project
myself with him you couldn't you
couldn't what reject myself with him
okay and he was the nice guy yeah yeah
so you you broke up with the nice guy
okay it's just
killing this whole thing wow why with TV
you can't make this up it's not
it's not because he's a nice guy that
wouldn't leave him like come on this
mood to okay well what was what was the
problem do you have a good did he have a
job yeah okay so he had a job so the
money he said you want to provide or a
mail he just wasn't going no like what
what was going wrong I just couldn't
protect myself with him that was not a
bad boy yeah it was not a bad boy it was
too nice it was too nice no no so I want
to know like why right you're right but
there had to be a reason right like you
know
um if you have a boyfriend and you like
him and then one day you're like I don't
like him and then there has to be a
reason
if I could project myself with him as in
what's the reason yeah but like why
couldn't
but like I said I'm virgin so
that's also like a pressure as well
because you can't stay in a long
relationship so why don't you just get
married because I couldn't see myself
getting married to him okay why why
that's the point it was not a bad boy
and this is why okay see this is why we
don't listen to what women say okay
because you guys you got we act
differently than what we say I used to
be like this you know until you look you
look into what we do and maybe you feed
a little bit if he's a little less
boring guy a little more excitement
which the Bad Boys bring maybe maybe you
could have seen yourself with him even a
healthy balance could have change the
course of yeah I think so because your
keeping was like he was a nice guy yeah
it sounded foreign
you get me but you can be nice and
charismatic yeah of course so so what do
you disagree with you didn't you don't
think that women date out of our league
no we do know what I was thinking about
The Tick Tock that you posted when he
said about a woman wants like drug
dealers and stuff like that I disagree
with that I agree with the fact that
everyone's bad boys but not really all
to that extent that's level to the
Badness
okay who do you think has an easier Time
dating a drug dealer or a nerd sorry a
drug dealer okay who has an easier Time
dating of course okay so so we do like
the drug dealers
generally generally yeah I would say
that okay okay so would you disagree
with that no I disagree with the fact
that you make it a a general thing okay
because as you said there's level to the
Badness what did you think of the first
guy the the simp yeah that was a real
Sim okay yeah and it was very fake so it
was easy to detect that you just want to
get into our plants right yeah it's a
realistic thing that happens day to day
and this is what gives a lot of delusion
to what it actually said because there
are men that actually go out of their
way and make it their cause to
lotion the females they get me in order
to get that it's their only hope it's
their only that's how they you know it's
their
you know so what did you think
yeah I mean it's quite accurate yeah not
well I'm not looking for a murderer but
um yeah it's quite accurate a lot of
guys do like
um a lot of girls who like bad boys I I
used to but now I just feel like those
are the kind of guys that will cheat on
you of course yeah well your top two
four like you're mixed six foot Rich
studs gonna cheat on you too I don't
know what you're do you think that men
don't cheat do you actually believe all
men cheat
this in perspective so why would you
take the cheating as um
what level they are anyway
it's wrong that's wrong it's only
because you guys only see the men that
cheat that's exactly I was going to say
so when when women say all men cheat
this is because you just you are you're
literally locked into just this small
subset of men maybe you actually don't
even notice
I want you to I want you to play a game
I want you to walk down the street okay
and I want you to count how many men you
see and I want you to count all of them
not just the one in your heads and I
want you to ask yourself how many you
would date
yeah and I like Tesco workers the coffee
shop guy I want you to like ask and not
just go on a date with like date just
think of it yeah yeah how many no not
many things like hardly any at all well
and that's the point you know so yeah
and exactly because it's a very good
it's a very good is awake today yeah
he's awake
I see I see I see like Hope on the couch
most times I just look at that cat and
I'm like ah nah done I see Hope on the
couch together
the thing is the thing is the reason why
that
um exercise is very good is because it
would literally tell you where you're
going wrong because the reality is if
you're able to dis this um disregard
disregard so many men just based on your
first look that means you're more likely
not going to find the right man for you
because really and truly you're not even
giving a man the chance to show you his
character which what we said
and like if you look at a man for his
finances and all of that these are
things that are very fleeting a man can
be a millionaire today and he can be
broken tomorrow but what could always
remain is characteristics so if it's a
man that would always work hard to make
sure he puts food on the table even when
he goes broke he's going to make sure he
takes care of you yeah characters
important but it's probably not the
first thing you see once you get exactly
we're gonna one date with the person I
get it but the problem is the first
thing you guys are looking at most well
most women I won't say you ladies but
the first thing most women are looking
at is they're looking at the looks that
steps above what they should be looking
at
again but yeah they do but then you need
to be really and that's why we say you
need to be realistic and this is why you
need to look at yourself and look at
where you are at in life so if if you're
always looking for these gorgeous guy
you're literally looking for trouble
but again as you said if men are doing
everything possible for them to get into
our pants so therefore if a value man
comes to us normally we should think
that everything that is saying is going
to be a lie exactly so based on that if
you're going with this um thinking
whatever is going to say about him and
his character would be a lie no but this
is where it comes down to the fact that
you shouldn't always you should in fact
you shouldn't even be using your own
brain to measure what a man whether a
man is good for you or not I should
actually rely on other people rely on
other men in your life that you trust
the vet man for you rely on friends
don't rely on women but how do you do
that no no I agree with what you're
saying like you're done no no I agree
what you're saying I'm saying that in a
dating like modern dating life when
you're meeting someone you're going on
dates and stuff like that for example my
culture will not allow me to have any
money in my Entourage yeah to even vouch
for this guy because for me to bring a
man is because I've validated that
manner do you have um like two parents
yes okay so have you ever asked your dad
to help you find a husband never why not
no it did like nowadays because I'm a
certain age yeah so he's asking me about
what is going on in my dating life right
because I don't bring anybody to the to
the house but it's not a situation where
I can date someone and bring that person
to my dad like that no okay well I was
saying you're saying date someone what
does that mean usually in modern days
there's usually sex involved you should
be having sex with anyone you haven't
vetted
because you said and based on what you
said that I need other men around me to
vote for that guy for me to be
understanding his character and
everything and I'm telling you in this
nowadays Modern Life dating whatsoever
if I'm just dating someone and I'm
trying to see his character I'm saying
I'm saying you shouldn't be going so I
should not if you want to marry you
shouldn't be going out to look for your
husband
rely on so the easiest way to find a
good husband is to go in your friend
group and go and meet other people go in
your social group actually meet men
through your social groups here just
meeting random men on the street and
trying to no do you have any I have a
question do you have any guy friends
yeah male friends yeah yeah yeah you do
yeah I do okay
um there's your husband
[Music]
that's your level if you want to know if
you want to know your level look at your
guy friends I don't really believe in no
job that's here that's men and women
there you go that's your level no men
men don't hang around women they're not
attracted to yeah that's why the reason
why I don't believe in um right so there
you go there's your husband are they
good are they good men
yeah someone okay so but miss you like
good men don't you there you go
[Laughter]
there you there you go and if you don't
like them you go to your dad that is the
best that's the best that's the best
person I don't think so as well I was
going to say in the vet and said what
king was saying women use some a part of
it is a part of vetting in Dayton is
having sex as well
so when you're saying don't have sex
with someone you're dating that
sometimes in the modern world is the vet
in process that if they don't have sex
with the guy and know whether he's good
or not they're not gonna take it to that
level because he could be all of the
other things but then when it comes to
the sex part of things now it's not
going as they would expect then they're
gonna kind of shut it down that's why
because the Modern Woman I wish I had my
chart because of how many women sorry
it's because of how many men that
they've slept with so now they're
they're like oh sex matters yeah
would you
um settle for a man that have everything
that you want but sexually is not like
providing for you we still settle for
that what do you mean no will you go for
a man that you have seen everything and
you like everything about him is like
and you
[Music]
my bad
I hope you're a real virgin
I've had too many come on the show and
they lie they lie yeah and they then
I'll hear about someone they slept with
and I'm like what the what you said
women will still even if they had sex
and the sex was like nothing but if if
everything else she's still gonna settle
for that man for a period of time she
will stand up for that for a period but
notice how you said ticks every other
single yeah every obviously he only
takes half and then that's the
difference
but then most women would be like well
if he takes the sex but he doesn't tick
the other half then I'll still go for
him and that is true
that's true and even the even the fact
that we keep saying settling sorry men
are settling for us nowadays so you're
bringing a kid in this and you're gonna
you're gonna say that yeah yeah he's
settle in for a single mom you know you
know I'm not going for men without kids
all right wait so I don't go well yeah
but without kids right but women love
men with kids why do you think these
guys get like men yeah yeah yeah
well you might say that around me now
okay I'll give you an example so if I if
I um and I'm someone I would prefer to
date men without kids however I can even
even don't knowing that I can
acknowledge
when I see a guy with his daughter or
his son there's something about it that
makes you just go on and it's cute I
might go oh but I'd be like okay next
well well and you know I I just have to
say the data will tell you that men a
lot of times have an easier time after
having children because again
historically we can't get rid of our
evolutionary roots and if you know sir
over there got you pregnant and you
pregnant that means oh he could protect
those two chicks right so then I that's
pre-selection you know so on the other
hand when a woman has a kid that signals
to a man that she's promiscuous yeah
yeah so yeah yes well well I mean it
shows that at least one other guy's been
there
right right right right so but that's
that's the point is like men want to
men's worst like biological fear is
passing on resources to a kid that's not
theirs and that happens like 20 of the
time now men are raising kids that
aren't theirs
so knowing this right
um it's like a negative for the win
unfortunately it's just a double
standard yeah but yeah I'm just I'm not
removing the fact that he's negative
what I'm saying is like you need to
understand your environment for you to
go for the people that can that you can
match
right right no and I agree with you but
I think my my point more is that it's
just interesting how we keep saying
settling because again we've been so
deluded into thinking we're all more
special than we are maybe but that's not
and it's funny that's not that's not
what'll sell millions though I can make
so much money tomorrow if I just started
motivation if I use this this gift of
mine to just speak to women and say you
are a queen don't ever sell I can make
so much money yeah see she's like she's
writing I want to listen to that podcast
um what did you think Christine of the
video yeah I thought it was hilarious I
thought they were pretty accurate and
yeah I mean you just you look around and
women do like the the drug dealer
criminal types you know perhaps
people don't want to admit it but that
is what a lot of women go after and it's
it's all in our in our biology like um
and to do with what we're attracted to
you know we've all admitted we're
emotional beings right so if a man wants
to keep you interested he needs to keep
you emotionally interested well if I
just tell you yeah well honey you look
beautiful today and you know have a good
day at work every single day that gets
boring right we don't want to admit it
but that's not spiking all of our
emotions if we have a guy who one day
tells us up that we're beautiful the
next day he comes in he's in a mood we
don't know why we're trying to figure it
out
there is a reason that women love
falling asleep to crime documentaries
there is a reason women love horror
films because we're emotional beings and
we like things that are peaking all of
our emotions sometimes we just don't
want to make that because it does sound
a bit twisted to go do you know what Ted
Bundy was actually really charismatic
but
it's true we're emotional beings we
can't help it and it's okay to admit
that that's what we are
what did what did you think I've
um zacharya
it was very accurate I thought um the
second part was kind of accurate as well
when you think about it because
that list of things that the woman was
saying on a
on the on the list and then doing The
Tick Tock videos it is subconscious
things that they are really emitting
outside which is truth to the joke there
is truth to the joke like what they said
so I kind of agree with it
I kind of agree that's the problem I
think the problem is is that it's
subconscious and a lot of people don't
want to acknowledge that because you can
acknowledge things about yourself and
and recognize that they're subconscious
and bring them into your awareness but I
think nowadays women are fed the lie
that we don't need to do that and we can
just live in our Consciousness which is
all just over inflated ego and and
altered by all of the stuff that we have
around us telling us you know you're
beautiful you're a 10 you deserve this
you deserve that instead of
acknowledging
the whole thing we're just sort of tuned
into this you know I'm this I'm That
Kind of mindset and when they're when
we're honest with ourselves it's like
you can kind of adapt like you know for
example we like bad boys so knowing this
maybe we should stay away from the bad
boys because if you surround yourself
well one's bound you know what I mean
like that's why dads used to there used
to be the boys that the dads would keep
away from us they'd be like stay away
from my daughter the dad knew that man
will ruin my daughter's life he would
stick with like a shotgun so now I think
that women love an X bad boy
he was about his business back in the
day and he can look after me and he has
got a history but right now he
understands that age and what we're
planning is a bit different so he has to
tone it down but he's got that trait
that's what I think women yeah and we
wanna and the problem is we want to tame
them we want it to be us because we have
been told this other dream that's like
you um all men will settle down for the
right woman yeah no that is the one baby
they are ready to settle and for with
his
best at the time yeah see she's like oh
I liked that dream no no no you're not
like no no chick is special enough that
she's gonna she's so special like think
about this what woman is that special in
2023 that she was so amazing and
phenomenal that she just made a man
change his entire life
for her what do you mean by that well um
he's a bad boy so he's just you know
screwing everybody the only man that's
gonna do that is a man that you can
control which we hate yep yep yeah well
I might not find some form of religion
and is convicted by his old ways and
decides to change completely based on
his Deen or religion right but it's not
the woman no it's not it's his own
conviction his own choice well and it's
funny because all the only the women
that like have been successful in that
it's like the steel like Steve Harvey's
about to get divorced yeah what I'm not
shocked at all yeah
I heard it was fake news just wait I
we've been in the red pill a long time
we predicted Jada way before Jada
happened we pray we we know we like I'm
telling you just give it give it a year
they'll be done Steve Alvin is okay yeah
that's news yeah I mean she's clearly
another Jada like that chick
like so obvious no she liked the she
really liked the gangsters and she
obviously is not so well that's the
thing like yeah because the thing is we
see all these like dating advice like
Steve Harvey which tells us to make
these rules for men but the men we like
they don't they don't play by the rules
do you the women hate men that they can
control we hate it and so what will
happen is these chicks will give us
dating advice and they'll say hey do
this do the three month rule do this do
this do this and then you'll get a guy
and on paper we'll see okay they have a
guy that's amazing maybe let's do that
but the problem is again it goes to the
woman controlling the man and we we hate
that no we do we hate it
like do you guys want to control a man
that's all no no no
well I'm gonna read um I'm gonna read
the super chats and then I think we're
gonna do final thoughts you guys are
very open-minded sometimes I can't call
women fat everyone gets mad but I
was like this was a very fun show today
okay Ryan Pearl please play
do you guys have time for one more video
that's cool you want one more okay
um King and while I read these super
chats um can you look up whole maths
dating down
um Okay so
please all right Ryan says Pearl please
play home maths dating Down video for
the ladies on the panel who say they
can't find a good man Dr David Baker all
men cheat get real lady
wait wait between between ages 18 and 25
women cheat 30 more frequently than men
only about a third of men of all ages
cheat sometime in their lives half of
them cheat once and never do so at a
guest do so again first coffee then air
um skill and sex can be lured and
improved if you have a growth mindset
comparing him to the hundred guys you
slept with all along making a final
judgment is dumb puffy Vegas stop the
cap ladies I asked out my I was asked
out on a date my first date at 12 I'm 49
now I've known it thousands of women
I've never met one that was faithful if
you include kissing Dr David Baker women
evolved to women evolved to be attracted
to dark Triad traits because the
Paleolithic murder rate was
approximately 10 percent in such a world
it was viable reproductive strategy to
be on the arm of a violent psychopath
Rumble Rumble rocks did Roe change his
tone to be more masculine Andrea gray
this is Andrea's husband but what most
women don't realize is that the level
they usually qualify for is the guys
they put in the friend zone women have
always had great choices but dismiss
them enter black dragon by the way women
submit to random men every day firemen
police officers professors bosses for
the men that love and marry you and also
disrespect
um but for the but the men that love and
marry you get disrespect and problems
that's true right they marry us they
it's so funny because we trust these men
with our children and our bodies but we
can't listen to what they say isn't that
backwards and we can't give them our
money we always are our gut is well I
can't give them my money what if he
leaves it's like well you trusted him
with your your body Deborah
your womb you gave him your womb like
you can't give him the money like all
right Chris thank you ladies I would not
be able to keep my stable of side chicks
if I wasn't for women like you you
co-signing the lies I tell them you help
it you you're helping us High net worth
men pump and dump these girls on birth
control thank you Andrea gray ten
dollars well you know what you know what
I actually I'm not even gonna shame you
sir thank you for being honest
they just tell us what we want to hear
so they can sleep with us enter black
dragon dragon what modern women do not
realize is being did I read this one
um what modern women do not realize is
that being feminine submissive and fit
can get you everything you want in a
good man I'm 40 years old dating a 21
year old your ego keeps you single by
your choice of men you can be better if
you try did I read that no you didn't
read it okay I think that was the last
one I'm gonna refresh it because I think
I saw one more
Sabrina I truly enjoyed this episode
thank you for the open-minded discussion
uh let's let's play the last video today
foreign
shorts
fading down
seeing a trend of women dating down
which means you know the man who so it
looks like women are getting victimized
again uh women are having to date down
because there are no good men left let's
talk about why
so usually men make more than women
which is not fair let's not talk about
why we'll just assume it's oppression so
to combat this oppression we need the
government to make laws so that women
can make an equal amount of money which
is fair and once women are making an
equal amount of money now uh men who
make less than them are losers
women are getting educated and they have
standards so they're not going to date
down she needs a man who makes more
money than her which is not fair
government help
so basically women need to be making the
same amount of money as men or even more
because it's 2023. that's the year that
it is that's this is the year and so the
government has to make this happen
because it's it's August 23rd the logic
is flawless
so all women should be equal to or
better than men and all women should be
able to find a man who makes more money
than she does where have all the good
men gone I just don't get it
I just don't understand it I got
educated and that's something that men
care about a whole lot
so now me and all the other educated
women are looking for men and they're
all busy what's going on here
I want a man who makes six figures
because that's more than me and that's
not fair so I should be making six
figures and when I get my six figures I
I want a man who's making seven figures
why can't I find any and when I do find
a man who makes seven figures that's
oppressive government help I'm so sick
of all this dating down why don't you
just do better hey you can't do better
government
why can't I raise my standards and make
a lot of money and then find a guy who
makes more money who doesn't have a lot
of women I just don't get it it's the
mystery of our time
guys it's really simple you got to get
out there and and climb that ladder and
when you do climb that ladder then
you're an evil bastard and you need to
be forced to share and when you do share
then you're a loser better climb
that ladder buddy
why can't all men be better than all
women while we also have enforced
equality it just does not make sense
yeah so what'd you guys think I wanted
to agree that was the best yes
yeah because it's like We complain we're
like we want to make more money and then
we make more money and then we say well
I can't make a date a guy that makes
less than me or whatever sit up no no
not you remember I'm not remember this
is the problem when women we hear things
it's always like what do I think but
it's like I'm talking about you've heard
women say I the girl in the beginning I
Need a Man On My Level well
the the thing is a lot of times when you
get money you become the things that men
hate yeah money doesn't take the level
money doesn't dictate it yeah I have a
question could you marry one of the men
in this room a girl that was if you
found a hot McDonald's worker
that was like yeah let's just give her a
virgin a virgin hot McDonald's worker
could you could you marry her is that
all right I could marry a virgin hot
McDonald's look yeah yeah as I will lead
her to be
McDonald's worker well she my wife right
mother
what about you guys McDonald's worker
anybody nah
that's the thing man yeah yeah exactly
exactly women can't level you down what
where's the levels to down
like my above is not I'm not just above
a McDonald worker so if I have to go
look down and have a man that is making
less than me he's not going to be the
level of a McDonald's worker
okay she did you get like it's just that
what makes it it's gonna be like the if
I was a McDonald worker and he was two I
wouldn't mind no but if I'm doing yeah
right but see but see we're going this
default right where we're saying well
but you know I'm going down but your
money doesn't matter so like not to men
oh yeah to men no correct but that's but
that's what we're talking about dating
it always has to be like what the men
want and do we offer that sure
yeah so I thought that was amazing I
think this guy's so that's that example
that example of the McDonald's workers
it's quite a lot because if us as men
are willing to do that and Elevate our
woman to a point of where I dearly would
like them to be but the women who are
single by choice wouldn't do the same
thing to the guy that potentially could
be that person that they ideally want
because but because of his position in
that workplace they're not even giving
you know what I'm trying but I get what
you mean but again it's about like I'll
do that I'll help my man to to get to my
levels
wait wait
what happened with your baby daddy then
why didn't you elevate I did you see
examples
how old
do you have a son do you have a son or a
daughter a son okay so you have a son
yes and for two years does he have a job
now no yeah what does he do he's working
at Amazon so why don't you get back with
him because he has other kids with
another woman and he's been a long time
that we're not together okay so how long
has it been your kid's only two no he's
ten
I misunderstood but so again we look at
like what you do versus what you say and
I did and I did my job no because I'm
saying like he has a job now so it seems
like he would have been a good Prospect
and find him jobs uh finding education
everything that could be as a woman as
my job I did okay well then why was he
able to do it after but he didn't do it
at the time so
okay but you see my point is that you
did not build him because you left
so you can't say you would build a guy
up because two years two years isn't
that long of a time
okay okay no but you said you would you
said you would yes I would but again you
didn't so we can't say you would if you
did it again that's what I'm saying
about environmental environmental so he
he had no job at the time at all oh
nothing he was studying and then oh so
he did he have he was in school yes it
was
you painted a complete what was he in
school for football
okay so okay so you he but what was his
actual degree in the sport management or
something okay okay so you picked an
athlete guy yeah okay
so again again you so he he and I've
done college sports you don't have a lot
of free time
no so you you made my neighbors
to see each other but my my whole point
is is you painted a whole picture that
was false and this is how I want I wanna
I'm gonna pay I'm gonna I'm gonna wait
I'm gonna I'm gonna I wanna point out
how women tell stories right no but what
because wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait okay the story she told was he was
unemployed and basically you made it
seem like and I need you to wait till I
finish
yeah he was a bum right and then I asked
like two questions and this is a guy in
school getting a degree for sports
management playing football
so he's not an unemployed bum the way
that she's selling that question because
as I said he was when I met him when the
kid was born he was no more okay okay
so now now it's switching now now okay
it's all right sorry okay it's okay so
when when did he become unemployed
unemployed he was my son was three
months okay so he was unemployed for
about two years two okay so so and he
did no other job he did to find the one
I found him okay so you found him a job
and then he worked the job he worked the
job a few times and a few weeks and then
he just stopped because he can't do just
like that okay what was the job cleaning
working restaurants okay okay so he
didn't want to do those jobs but now
he's worried how long has he worked at
Amazon I don't know okay but he's worked
at Amazon Amazon's a pretty King used to
work it that's a pretty tough job yeah
so like to me this isn't making sense
that he works Amazon and he wouldn't
work there's 10 years difference in
between the time it was 18 at a time and
now it's no more okay okay well I think
he has over responsibilities of the kids
so now he has to be forced to do job
because at the time I was providing I
was taking care of the bills I was
taking care of everything okay so you
didn't need to okay well my my whole
point was it it still isn't the picture
that you originally set that's exactly
what's it did I say anything no no no
you made it like he was unemployed the
whole time when he was a student he gets
out he gets out okay he gets out of
school right and he had a hard time
finding a job in his field right now but
the problem is he knew that she was
pregnant and he didn't have a job and he
that did still didn't push him to his
girlfriend she she has you don't know
that yeah no no but actually the problem
is not what you said the problem is
she selected for the wrong things yeah
yeah but now as in what so the type of
money from what you've said I can tell
he's probably he was probably tall good
looking no no not at all it was shorter
than me okay so you see that you can't
say anything that you don't know okay
but okay I'm trying to and you see the
reason why is because of his character
that was with him not because of his
money do you see this is where you
should have asked what character because
the character he was a very kind person
no no I'm telling you you're going to
you as a character because what I'm
saying is you clearly just stated that
he he has he doesn't have a good work
ethic yes yes good so that should be
part of the things you should be looking
at as I said we have to understand we
met we were 14 years old that was the
first person that was in love with we
were in relationship for 16 years old so
at this time you can't have a work ethic
the only thing you can see it's worth 16
years old we'll see yeah
true no in France I'm telling you what
at 16 years old my first job was 16. uh
yes I I was in I'm telling you in France
here when he was doing football sports
in a very sensitive what did your what
did your dad think of him he hated him
okay
only when I was pregnant okay so your
dad hated him when I was pregnant
because I was pregnant which goes back
to I I don't think you selected him for
character because you didn't even bring
him to your dad I didn't bring into my
dad but you have to understand the
background to it as well I knew I was
pregnant six months in the pregnancy so
there's nothing different why weren't
you on birth control I was okay out of
denial okay so you only okay I I just
have a hard time believing this it's
true okay let me let me when women when
women tell me this I was on a micro
contraception and because of anemia I
was not working so it was only working
45 that's the reason why I got pregnant
on contraception okay because it was in
incorrectly no it was a mini pill so
many people doesn't work 90 when you
have blood complication because of
anemia okay
um but why did they put you on the mini
pill because I was so irregular because
of my anemia that's the reason why I
have to put me on the pill very early
since I had my period for me I mean why
did they put you on the mini pill I
don't know that's what it was available
at the time okay I just I just find that
interesting yeah it's just you only get
pregnant like three days a month five
days a month if that was enough I'll go
printing I I I I know it's just a lot of
the things you're saying in these
stories like don't add up they don't
make sense so what is
um I I don't understand how you got five
days a month you can get pregnant you
have plan B you have birthday you have
tried no plan B I was on birth control I
never tried right I just I just think
most of the time when women get pregnant
it's a choice I don't think it's an act
as much at 18 years old it was not a
choice yeah I just got no time to
believe in that it was sorry but I I
just yeah there's 40 forms of birth
control you get pregnant three days
in the environment I didn't even know
what birth control was around my area I
don't think all that is the issue like I
think all that is aside is the issue the
real issue is you were engaging in
things you shouldn't happening I totally
agree that one that's my point 100 so
meaning at that age like you said
correctly maybe you you you you didn't
select well for the right because you
went you shouldn't have been selecting a
guy at that age fully agree with the
fact that I shouldn't have been sexual
with someone at that age for me to be
able to make the right decision this is
a fact but what I'm saying is after the
decision was made origin and the factors
are done
it's up to him to act the way he wants
to act and it's up to me to try my best
to lead him to that level yeah no no I'm
not I'm not even putting you that I
think because this is what we're talking
about you've dealt with the situation
however you had to do exactly the point
is at the end of the day this is why we
do this show because it's like us
pointing out this is not even to like
highlight anything about your life it's
more like for the younger people this is
a lesson for people to learn and this is
the reason why I hate it when women
don't come out and be honest about
things that they have been through
because what you're doing is you're
denying a younger girl the the ability
to learn from your mistakes
like literally at that age you shouldn't
even be engaging in things like that no
that's that's definitely the fight
because if I did not was involved
sexually with him at the time I would
have not even had the possibility of
getting pregnant for me to get to have
to deal with the situation which is a
fact but we came back to why is the
reason why it was a bum and whatsoever
and I'm telling you that I've tried my
best I did try to like level up and try
to have him level up but it didn't so
there's much I can do but it also goes
back to what we're saying exactly but
it's still it's a vice Circle yeah women
shouldn't be vetting men for
relationships on their own because even
at young age old age there's no
difference even a 35 year old woman was
to sit on this couch and say the exact
same thing well uh I I he gave me the
wrong signal it's always the same story
so I think so I think by the oh yeah and
you would know the difference when I was
in my 20s I'd be able to vet someone
based on character and everything else
that's what you say but at the end of
the day we'll still watch what what
women do in general and if I have seen
so many older women that still fall for
the same bad boys that they fell for
when they were young yep with someone
that wasn't that didn't have the right
characteristics
but you'll sleep with them
yeah but I did birth control yeah but
you see there are women that have gotten
pregnant yeah exactly
so you're still going to make the wrong
way
then you you you then you don't have
anyone else to blame
yeah
but no actually if they really wasn't
right for me then I wouldn't sleep with
them I wouldn't date them at all
I'll take that with a pinch of salt
you can take as you like
well I do appreciate the honesty guys
you know I'm gonna give you guys a round
of applause I'm gonna give you you know
appreciate the honesty
um a couple super chats came in these
are not my opinions but the opinions of
the chat
um all right signed up just to say the
wall is going to be hard on the last in
the middle she has spent the entire show
and delusion her French boyfriend sold
drug sweets drugstore Sweets she can't
admit to it online oh did you was he a
drug dealer at all it was never involved
in the street whatsoever and still today
all right Sabrina I truly enjoyed this
episode thank you for the open-minded
discussion
um Pearl please oh I did that one Let me
refresh it real quick guys women
shouldn't vote shirts come on get your
shirts
um I've also been thinking I think it'd
be really funny to do something where
I I want to do it I need some feedback
from this idea from guests I want the
audience to be able to mute someone's
mic I think it'd be just funny or they
can't talk so like let's just say now
how long could I mute your mic without
you guys getting really pissed at me
because I don't I don't want the guests
to leave you know but I think it could
be a funny game they can they could even
mute my mic if they want I'll do it for
cash you know honestly yeah
a minute so if I did five minutes of
muting
you would be silenced no no no everyone
else could talk just not you oh for five
minutes
if one person is muted most people will
be quiet because in turn really would
have an effect on everyone else
let me know in the chat what would you
pay for how
how could I mute somebody that you would
pay for and I wanted to be like a
hundred bucks like this ain't no cheap
mute you know what I mean they gotta
they gotta lay down the law uh what's
the condition of the meat why are they
meeting yeah well I mean it's probably
the most annoying show guest now this
guest everyone's been pretty nice so but
there's shows where
there's like crazy chicks that start
yelling and it would just be so funny if
like they're yelling in a hundred bucks
they can't talk all right they say 30
minutes I think they would leave at 30
minutes too much
um at five minutes well okay guys this
is put it in the comments because this
is an idea I'm kind of playing with and
I just I think would be kind of funny
okay
um someone else from the ginger Menace
who's a new um
I knew what do you call it uh moderator
why don't you guys do your final
thoughts and where the people can find
you go ahead
uh my Instagram is the French girl
underscore one and yeah
that's all I have this is the same final
thoughts final thoughts on what
everything
I am
it was a good debate I would say I've
learned a lot to be honest I've learned
a lot
what's the best what's the best piece of
information you learned tonight
yeah she didn't go higher than
who I am really okay but that's
something that I already knew but it's
nice to like hear it and your difference
perspective and stuff okay go ahead okay
so my Instagram it's Sinchan underscore
no it's underscore Maria and final
thoughts is women not to blame for
everything
women are to blame is what it is so we
just know now it's more clear
that's what I was saying so do you
actually agree with that now or is that
your listen is this show made you now
change your perspective to believe that
women are now to blame I'm I'm not going
to tell that subject that you made me
change my mind but I always felt like
women were to blame anyway for
everything in the world so here's what
it is now even on dating us being single
it's our fault
my Instagram is amazing
underscore 27 my final thoughts are I
still want it 6.5 mix race guy that
makes more money than me and call me
deluded but that's my final thought oh
they will it's been a really interesting
show as well by the way
comments don't blame me I don't believe
uh my Instagram is at ijuda my business
Pages at struggle proof so hit them both
up my final thoughts are I've enjoyed
today it's been very insightful it's
been um good to hear the views of a
panel full of women I was kind of
um what's the word I was kind of
reluctant to like even be on a panel
when I found that it was just me and
four women and I was like oh word I got
set up like that but I think um it was
good either way it's good as a man to
listen to the women's perspective and
hear pose outlandish
um idealisms of things but they're quite
they're not they're they're a lot of
them are realistic but they are very
outlandish when you think of the I just
think women we can give at least three
kids today that's what I think I think
we should aim for three each let's
replace the population
[Laughter]
let's aim
assistant we're not all gonna hit it but
let's shoot for the stars ladies
go ahead
um you can find me on YouTube and
Instagram at Christine Grace Smith final
thoughts
this has been a very open-minded panel
honestly it's been quite refreshing to
be honest and yeah had a lot of fun
thank you for having me thanks for
coming chica I it's actually these are
my favorite type of shows actually when
I feel like people actually are coming
into an open mind not getting mad
um yeah which is better than last week
when last week I'll tell you what
happened I'll tell you guys I'm I'm in
one of my good moods so last week I had
um the guys and the girls give grades to
like what an A man is a b man and a c
and I went on the white board and I said
to the women like what is a c what does
it be and yeah one of the women she's
sitting right there she got so mad that
I yeah I had to tell her to leave
because she just kept like pouting but I
think it was just because I said that
only fans makes you like be an f and
like I think she had like a oh yeah she
had a yeah she you know only fans makes
it be a walk and a half I said like yeah
like that's like um oh oh the great yeah
yeah because I said ABC
you know if you have only fans your
failure as a woman
yeah I think she also did porn as well
I don't know we can't call that a
success right like we can't call that
out but then again modern society
Liberation your body there's different
differentiation
yeah exactly but this is what makes her
be so anti to the fact of what you're
saying because she's thinking wait a
second it's okay right now she should
give me a thank you because I'm like
this is how the men think thinks yeah
not just the man everybody yeah I'm like
yes most people yeah exactly like I
don't I don't she didn't thank me though
she left you kicked her out well I mean
it was almost like a self-kick out of
that we could agree she was sewing no no
we didn't kick out let me let me make
this clip she's been going at me online
choice I said if you're going to keep
disrupting the show you can leave and
she got up and left
I do think I said you can go but I guess
I I didn't say you have to go it was an
alpha I mean it was it was implied I
gotta be honest I actually think I saw a
clip of that I'm not even lying it's
actually coming back to me yeah I
actually saw it yeah I'm gonna search
for it I mean yeah that's Bill wine
there are a lot of whiners but I don't
know what to tell him modern women are
fat oh my God oh my gosh oh my
God
don't people come for you they must come
for you yeah oh yeah exactly that's the
every day of my life it's like they pick
apart and the funny thing is they never
say I'm the ideal I'm like don't there's
better women to look up to that are very
feminine like I'm not saying it's me but
I'm like I just think as a group we
gotta we gotta pick the ideal right we
gotta pick like these are the women now
the problem is we can't find them
anywhere
because there's a lot of no offense but
a lot of modern women that think they're
traditional and they're just not and we
just live in this delusion where we
think we're traditional we're not
traditional and I think out of all the
girls that have been on the show I could
think maybe five maybe and this is out
of hundreds of women I'm gonna find you
a ten a ten women that's I'm making a
mission
I can't find I haven't really found I
found maybe one girl that would have
been an a a hundred years ago I want one
I want I just want and this isn't hate
you know I just think we got to start
with virginity and that's that's tough
one
exactly that's what I'm saying but that
was like standard 100 years ago they
don't exist they're gone so anyways I'm
looking for one I have a search so I
want I want a woman I can bring in here
and then point to you as an A so let me
DM me on Instagram just pearly things
one like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel also guys
also women shouldn't vote shirt every
show we see now these women are more
reasonable today but they really
shouldn't be voting we got better things
to do we should be in the kitchen
cooking you know what I mean so women
should not vote the link to that is in
the description
um also go subscribe to whole math um he
should be in the comments or the
description or something if not
um just put it on on Youtube it'll come
up like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time